Anthony Deschud, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Olivier Mével, bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct.
Olivier Anthony qui veut commencer à se
présenter.
Bah je peux y aller ? Ouais. plaisir.
Donc je suis Anthony Deschud, je suis
réalisateur de cinéma, je suis également
acteur et je viens de réaliser mon
premier longmétrage qui s'appelle La
Guerre des prix qui est sortie mercredi
dernier au cinéma et qui est disponible
dans beaucoup de salles en France et qui
traite notamment des négociations entre
la grande distribution et les
fournisseurs, les industriels et toutes
les tous les impacts derrière sur la
chaîne alimentaire, notamment le revenu
des agriculteurs.
Olivier,
alors je suis maître de conférence à
l'université de Bretagne occidentale. Je
suis considéré comme un spécialiste
partage de la valeur ajoutée dans les
filières alimentaires. C'est-à-dire
qu'en fait, j'étudie intensément les
interactions entre les quatre maillons
que sont l'agriculture, la
transformation, la distribution et la
consommation.
Pourquoi vous avez décidé de faire ce
film ? Comment vous l'avez préparé avant
qu'on rentre dans le détail de comment
sont fait les prix, les impacts, le
consommateur, les producteurs, les
supermarchés.
Ouais.
Pourquoi ce film ? Bah, il faut revenir
un peu je pense sur mon parcours parce
que j'ai un parcours un peu particulier.
Avant d'être réalisateur, en fait,
j'étais pas du tout destiné au monde du
cinéma. Moi, j'ai fait des études
d'économie, de gestion dans une fac à
Paris qui s'appelle Dauphine. Et puis
après avoir fait ça, j'ai fait un voyage
d'un an en Amérique du Sud et en Asie où
je suis allé visiter des coopératives de
commerce équitable et j'ai fait un
espèce de petit documentaire pour des
magasins qui à l'époque s'appelaient les
magasins artisans du Monde. Et je pense
que ce voyage m'a déjà sensibilisé à ces
questions de la rémunération des
producteurs. Alors là, c'était plutôt
dans les pays du sud, mais finalement la
guerre des prix répond un peu à tout ça
dans les pays du dans en France. Et donc
après avoir fait ce voyage,
j'avais une volonté de rentrer en
entreprise et de vouloir un peu changer
le monde à ma manière, mais je me suis
vite rendu compte que c'était difficile.
Et euh un jour, je suis allé voir un de
mes amis jouer au théâtre, il jouait le
balleurs de Jean Nouille et il s'amusait
beaucoup sur scène et moi je m'ennuyais
beaucoup dans mon travail et donc je me
suis dit, je vais devenir comédien,
enfin en tout cas, je vais essayer
d'aller faire du théâtre. On va revenir
sur le côté éducation populaire grâce au
cinéma.
Ouais.
On va vous avez préparé le scénario avec
lui, vous l'avez conseillé. Comment ça
se passe ? B
je pense que je suis une des premières
personnes qu'il est venu voir. Je me
rappelle encore bien de la la rencontre
avenue de l'opéra et puis j'ai été
surpris parce que Anthony posait déjà de
vraies questions et donc il avait
l'intention surtout
C'est quoi les vraies questions ? Les
vraies questions c'était de savoir bah
finalement c'est vrai que ça se passe
comme ça. C'est vrai que dans le fond
les négociations commerciales, il y a de
la violence. C'est vrai qu'il y a de
l'intimidation. C'est vrai que dans le
fond on y pratique aussi des choses que
la société civile ne tolérerait
forcément pas. La réponse était oui. Et
je lui ai dit peut-être Anthony, on va
prendre les sujets les uns après les
autres. Et puis ça devait rester euh une
un entretien d'une trentaine de minutes.
Puis on est resté très longtemps. Il
griffonnait et puis ensuite m'a
recontacté et j'ai bien vu qu'il était
dans le sujet, qu'il avait dû voir
d'autres personnes, qu'il a dû
s'intéresser profondément finalement à
son sujet et à la fin euh il me dit "Ben
ça y est, le scénario est presque là."
Et puis bah j'ai eu bonheur de pouvoir
des fois le reconseiller. Et puis quand
j'ai découvert le film, ça a été un
choc.
Le film part de quoi ? Qu'est-ce qu'il y
a de chaud dedans ? Qu'est-ce que la
population peut apprendre dedans ?
Bah plein de choses. Pour revenir à ta
première question, juste finir parce que
c'est important quand même. Qu'est-ce
qui m'a donné envie de de faire ce film
là ? C'est une expérience un peu
particulière. Un jour, je me suis
retrouvé euh dans le séminaire annuel
des acheteurs d'une ancienne de grande
distribution et j'étais comédien et j'ai
fait une intervention de théâtre à
l'entreprise. Je me suis retrouvé
là-dedans et donc j'ai observé ce
séminaire et il y a euh un des
dirigeants de la centrale d'achat de
cette enseigne qui a pris la parole pour
introduire ce séminaire et qui a dit
voilà si on est réuni ici aujourd'hui
c'est pour savoir qui dans cette salle
sont des requins et qui sont des requins
tueurs. Nous on veut pas de requins, on
veut que des requins tueurs. Moi,
j'étais sur mon siège comme je disais
tout à l'heure, j'ai bossé en entreprise
pendant quelques années et je suis pas
naï. Je sais que le monde d'entreprise,
il est dur, il est il peut être violent.
Mais là, ce que j'ai entendu ce jour-là,
j'ai jamais entendu des discours aussi
violents. Et donc en sortant de cette
cette journée, je me suis dit "OK, il
faut que je fasse des recherches, faut
que je rentre dans cet univers juste par
curiosité."
En quelle année ça ?
Ça c'était en 2018. Ouais, c'est ça. Et
donc j'ai commencé à faire des
recherches sur internet, à regarder des
documentaires, des reportages et de fil
en aiguille, je me suis dit tiens, il
faut que je rencontre des gens qui
travaillent dans cet univers là. Et donc
c'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré
Olivier qui en est fait la première
personne que j'ai rencontré. Et moi,
j'ai découvert un monde à la fois
fascinant mais aussi effrayant et très
très très brutal. Donc Olivier, je me
souviens de la première phrase qui m'a
dite à peu près la façon dont on s'est
rencontré où il m'a dit à votre avis
c'est quoi un acheteur ? Moi, j'ai
débarqué de façon très simple et naïve.
Je dis bah un acheteur c'est quelqu'un
qui reçoit des fournisseurs et qui va
essayer de négocier les prix et décider
qu'est-ce qu'il va mettre dans ses
rayons, dans ses supermarchés. Il m'a
dit "Non, non, c'est pas ça. Un
acheteur, c'est quelqu'un qui extorque
de la marge de façon psychologique."
Et ça, c'est une phrase que c'est une
des première phrase que j'ai noté sur
mon petit cahier là quand il parlait de
que je prenais des notes sur nos
entretiens.
Ils sont peut-être pas tous comme ça.
Bah, en tout cas, moi c'est comme ça que
je suis rentré dans dans le sujet et ça
m'a ça m'a ça m'a troublé parce que moi,
j'avais une image un peu euh je sais pas
ce que les gens euh se disent sur cet
univers-là, mais j'avais un peu une
image de euh
un peu de négociation marchand de tapis
quoi où euh on se négocie des prix dans
des boxes comme ça, c'est un monde dur,
on joue les gros bras mais rien de très
évolué. Mais lui m'a décrit des
techniques de manipulation psychologique
très poussé. Est-ce qu'il peut nous les
décrire ?
Bah ces techniques finalement euh
s'apparenteent au dilemme du prisonnier.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait il y a une
entreprise et puis euh un homme, un
groupe d'acheteurs face à face. Et
finalement, il y a quatre possibilités.
C'est-à-dire que il y a oui non possi
chaque côté mais il y a que deux
situations qui intéressent. Le oui oui
ou le non ? Non. Le oui oui on fait du
commerce ensemble. le non, on fait rien
ensemble. Et pour aller au Wii euh et
pour obtenir l'optimisation du Wii ce
qu'on appelle nous un équilibre de nche,
c'est-à-dire le meilleur équilibre
possible, sachant que à partir de là et
ben on peut pas aller plus haut parce
que sinon il y a quelqu'un qui perd sur
sa position. Et l'acheteur de la grande
distribution euh il va être formé
de façon à pouvoir faire pression,
utiliser un rapport de force jusqu'au
bout. C'est comme dans le théâtre
finalement, unité de lieu, unité de
temps, mais à un moment donné, il y en a
un qui va être plus fort que l'autre et
il va lui faire comprendre sa
toutepuissance et il va lui demander de
lâcher sur le prix. Pourquoi ? Ceun
distributeur, il ne crée rien. Il ne
crée rien. C'est-à-dire que le maillon
agricole travaille, s'occupe des
cheptel, s'occupe des bêtes, du végétal,
H24,
prends le risque sanitaire, prends le
risque environnemental, prends le risque
financier, transfère ce risque aux
industries agroalimentaires. Les
industries agroalimentaires travaillent
les produits de l'autre côté et ensuite
le distributeur va recevoir les produits
de tr jours dans ses magasins. Ce qui
pose problème effectivement, c'est que
des centrales d'achat, si super
centrales d'achat en France, les
centrales d'achat européennes, on en
parlera peut-être après, ben elle
constituent finalement une garde de
triage dans lequel ils vont trier des
produits et exiger d'avoir ces produits
dans les volumes qu'il souhaitent et
dans les prix qu'il souhaitent. Et ça
pose un problème parce que 325000
agriculteurs sont confrontés à ce
problème. 325000 agriculteurs qui
vendent à 2300 coopératives et 18000
entreprises de l'agroalimentaire. Une
soixantaine de multinationales mais au
bout il y a que six centrales d'achat de
la grande distribution qui eux-mêmes
vendent à 68 millions de killers. Les
comptes sont vite fait. C'est-à-dire que
celui qui tient la place du milieu, là
où est le goulet d'étranglement du
sabliier, il vend à 68 millions. Il a
des milliers d'acheteurs. On appelle ça
nous un oligopole bilatéral, la franche
non concurrentielle. C'est la meilleure
place pour être sur le marché.
C'est-à-dire que vous pouvez faire des
marges à l'achat, vous pouvez faire des
marges à la vente, vous pouvez déporter
vos marges comme vous le voulez, mais au
bout du compte, vous serez toujours le
vainqueur.
Médecin en image, comment vous avez fait
? Mais tu sais en image, bah comment tu
as fait ?
Ouais. Comment j'ai fait ?
Ah ça après donc ça c'est un travail de
de cinéas, de mise en scène. Moi je me
suis basé sur un principe de base qui
était de confronter deux mondes, deux
univers. Moi je crois que dans le cinéma
ce qui est important c'est on filme des
lieux aussi. Et donc il y avait ce monde
de l'entreprise de la négociation donc
représenté par le siège de cette
enseigne. Et puis il y a un monde de la
ferme. Donc j'ai choisi en fait de
d'avoir un personnage qui soit écartelé,
un personnage principal qui soit
écartelé entre ces deux mondes. Et donc
j'ai décidé en fait de d'organiser toute
ma mise en scène en fonction de ce ce
point-là, c'est-à-dire comment je
confronte ces deux univers.
Le personnage clé, qu'est-ce que qui
estce ? Donc le personnage, c'est une
jeune femme qui est euh fille d'éleveur
laitier, qui s'appelle Audry, qui est
interprétée par Ana Gérardo et euh donc
qui vient du monde agricole mais qui a
décidé de s'en séparer un petit peu.
Elle travaille dans la Grande
Distribution au début du film. Elle est
chef de rayon dans un hypermarché en
province en Normandie. Et puis elle est
elle est très sensible au bio, au local,
du fait de son histoire et de sa
famille. son frère a repris la ferme et
puis elle est repérée par le siège de
son ancienne qui va la propulser à la
centrale d'achat en lui disant "On a
besoin de profil comme vous pour pouvoir
pousser le bio le le local et donc vous
êtes la bonne personne pour faire ça."
Elle elle s'attend pas du tout à ça.
Elle débarque dans ce monde là et elle
le découvre et à travers le regard de de
ce personnage là j'embarque le
spectateur aussi pour qu'il découvre ce
mondeel et ce monde des négociations. Et
donc elle va être tiraillée entre ses
origines, ses racines, euh la la ferme
de son de son frère et puis son désir
aussi d'ascension sociale, de rentrer
dans ce système- làà, de prendre une
revanche, de défendre ses convictions,
mais de rencontrer des gens bah qui ont
des méthodes de faire qui sont parfois
impitoyables et qui vont lui demander de
faire des arbitrages.
Olivier, c'est quoi un requin tueur ?
Un requin de tueur, c'est quelqu'un dont
la mission est d'arracher effectivement
la valeur ajoutée à celui qui a
construit justement patiemment cette
valeur. Soit un agriculteur, soit une
industrie agroalimentaire, soit une
coopérative agroalimentaire. Et ce
requin de tueur va profiter d'un
simulacre. C'est-à-dire que la loi euh
est ainsi faite que les industriels
négocient avec la grande distribution 8
semaines dans l'année. Tout est
concentré sur 8 semaines. Donc c'est un
vrai théâtre dans lequel des milliers
euh on va dire d'industriel industriels
vont venir pour présenter leurs
produits. Mais seulement ils ne peuvent
pas tous être élus parce que les places
sur les linéaires sont chères et il faut
donc payer son loyer. et payer son
loyer, ça veut dire que il va falloir
accepter un certain nombre de choses que
naturellement il n'accepterait pas. On
appelle ça le rapport de forme
non parce qu'aujourd'hui ça s'est
moralisé. Ça c'est
dans le film, si je peux me permettre de
vous couper, dans le film à un moment il
y a il y a une centrale d'achat qui
demande 100000 €. H
Est-ce que on peut me décrire cette
scène là si on spoile pas trop le
Ouais, je veux pas trop spoiler, mais
c'est pas un back, c'est ce qu'ils
appellent une compensation. C'est une
demande de compensation.
Donc bon, on peut on peut rentrer
concrètement dans dans cette scène, mais
puis il y a la police qui vient après.
Ouais. Plus tard. Et c'est pas la c'est
pas exactement la police, mais c'est la
c'est la répression des fraudes. Ouais.
C'est l'autorité de la concurrence donc
qui qui fait une perquisition.
Euh mais oui, donc cette demande de
compensation, moi c'est des choses qu'on
m'a raconté parce que j'ai bien sûr j'ai
rencontré Olivier, mais j'en ai
rencontré d'autres hein, des je me suis
pas limité à une personne. Euh j'ai
rencontré aussi euh des industriels,
j'ai rencontré des acheteurs et des
acheteuses en poste qui ont témoigné de
façon anonyme, j'ai rencontré des gros
industriels, des plus petits. J'ai
rencontré des agriculteurs, des
éleveurs. J'ai j'ai vraiment fait une
enquête de plusieurs mois et ce qu'on
voit dans le film et notamment donc
cette séquence dont tu parles, c'est
directement tiré de ce que j'ai pu
recueillir comme comme témoignage et
comme expérience du du réel. Euh
l'exemple de ces 100000 € pour les
auditeurs, on peut dire une chose, un
industriel a vendu pour 1 million et
demi à donc la grande distribution. La
grande distribution, elle a mis un
coefficient dessus, c'est-à-dire qu'elle
a peut-être vendu ça 1,5 fois ce
prix-là. Et puis à la fin de l'année,
ben ils vont faire les comptes. Et donc
c'est ce qu'on appelle les RFA, les
remises de fin d'année. Et dans ces
remises de fin d'année, le distributeur
va dire "Ben voilà, tu me dois tant, tu
me dois 6 7 % en remise de fin d'année."
Et donc plus le distributeur est
puissant, plus l'entreprise est faible,
plus la remise sera importante. Et donc
à partir de là, le distributeur lui
négocie à plusieurs niveaux.
C'est-à-dire que le prix facial, le
premier prix annoncé est loin d'être le
prix final. Le premier prix, on appelle
le prix net. C'est-à-dire que dans le
fond, il inclut les remises, les
rabelles, les ristour classiques. Puis
après, il y a le prix de fo net,
c'est-à-dire un prix dans lequel on va
venir travailler un certain nombre de
coopérations commerciales, vraie ou
fausse. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, le
distributeur peut vous dire "Ben, je
vais vous faire de la publicité
effectivement sur mes catalogues
numériques. Je vous faire de la
publicité sur des réseaux sociaux.
vérifiable ou non vérifiable. De toute
façon, l'industriel doit payer. À partir
de là, l'industriel peut aussi se voir
reprocher le fait de
producteur l'industriel producteur
producteur peut se voir reprocher le
fait de ne pas être arrivé à l'heure en
centrale d'achat au lieu de livraison
pénalité logistique. C'est-à-dire que on
descend là en fait à un prix qui est
très différent du premier prix. Et puis
d'un côté le distributeur peut aussi
demander et donc quand je dis le
distributeur, ils sont pas tous aussi
puissants. Certains sont plus puissants
que d'autres et une
c'est peut-être pas tous comme ça non
plus.
Euh et ben dans ces cas-là effectivement
quand dans le monde de la distribution
n'est pas comme ça, on est viré du
marché. C'est l'exemple du groupe
casino, c'est-à-dire le groupe casino
qui a donc déposé son bilan et qui donc
est passé euh on va dire depuis 3 ans à
un stade où il déenait encore 7 8 % de
part de marché à 2,5 3 % aujourd'hui. Le
groupe casino avait des équipes d'achat
qui étaient pas au niveau de celle du
groupe Leclerc évidemment pas assez
violent, pas assez méchant. Et donc
c'est comme un apprentissage. Une équipe
d'achat ça demande à être préparée. Elle
demande à être affutée et certains
distributeurs comme le groupe Auchamp en
difficulté aujourd'hui ont des équipes
d'achat qui changent trop souvent. Le
leader avec ses 25 % de part de marché a
des équipes d'achat permanentes très
affutées. Quand vous n'êtes pas avec les
équipes d'achat qu'il faut généralement
vous êtes expulsé du marché et c'est
tout ce problème là. Et donc ça
c'est votre constatation ou c'est marqué
dans le marbre ou c'est une
extrapolation,
une suputation, une interprétation ? Non
non, c'est c'est c'est la c'est la
réalité. J'ai été auditionné par la
commission donc du Sénat sur commission
d'enquête sur les les marges de la
grande distribution et des industries
agroalimentaires. Et donc, j'ai présenté
mes travaux de recherche et il n'y a pas
de contestation, du moins j'ai pas eu de
contestation de la part des
distributeurs qui ont été interrogés par
les sénateurs d'ailleurs sur un certain
nombre de chiffres. Mais les chiffres
sont très clairs, c'est que dans ce
pays, on vit dans un pays où le
consommateur doit savoir que pour 100 €
alimentaires dépensés, il n'y a que 8 €
qui reviennent à l'agriculture. Et d'un
côté, on va demander aux agriculteurs
d'être toujours plus vert, d'encaisser
toujours plus de normes alors même que
seul 8 € sur 100 dépensés par le
consommateur arrivent finalement dans
les exploitations agricoles. Et donc
aujourd'hui, il y a pas assez d'euros
dans les cours de ferme pour garantir
notre sécurité, notre souveraineté
alimentaire. Et notre souveraineté
alimentaire, elle ne peut pas tenir
quand le socle agricole est en train de
mettre un genou à terre. Et un genou à
terre, ça veut dire qu'en 10 ans, on a
perdu plus de 100000 agriculteurs.
Aujourd'hui, 325000 agriculteurs actifs
jusqu'où ? Et on voit très bien que nos
productions de volaille aujourd'hui,
notre filière avicole, on voit bien que
notre filière aujourd'hui en poule
pondeuse, on voit bien en bovin, on voit
bien en port que nos niveaux de
production du mal augmenté pour beaucoup
de raisons, c'est polyfactoriel. Mais il
y a une raison particulier qui fait que
les agriculteurs ont mal au cœur, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui, on peut tout ramener à
un problème de revenu et aujourd'hui,
ils n'ont pas la valeur ajoutée qu'il
mérite. Pourquoi ? Parce que dans le
fond, la loi aussi est mal faite, mais
il y a pas que la loi. Il y a aussi un
rapport de force insupportable qui se
joue lors de ces 8 semaines dans lequel
en fait industriel et distributeurs vont
discuter et au bout de du compte, le
distributeur qu'est-ce qu'il va faire ?
Il ne va pas accepter le plan tarifaire.
Les négociations commerciales 2026 qui
se sont terminées au 1er mars ont été
catastrophi catastrophiques pour les
coopératives agricole qui s'en
reviennent expliquer aux agriculteurs
ben qu'elles n'ont pas eu les
augmentations de tarifaires qu'elles
souhaitaaient. Alors évidemment, c'est
le désarrois et on n'est pas sans savoir
que depuis 2023, 2024, 2025, le monde
agricole sort des fermes pour exprimer
sa colère. Et dans sa colère aujourd'hui
euh il y a une question au-delà des
normes, au-delà de l'application des
normes qui est celle du revenu. Et quand
on regarde aujourd'hui ce revenu
agricole, et ben d'une manière ou d'une
autre, nous consommateurs, on en est
responsable parce qu'au-delà des 100 €
alimentaires, il y a 8 € qui reviennent
à l'agriculteur. Les industries
agroalimentaires, c'est 15 €. Ça
signifie que ceux qui travaillent, ceux
qui prennent les risques ont moins
d'un/4 de la valeur ajoutée. Ça veut
dire que 75 % de la valeur ajoutée est
résolue en aval et touchée en aval. Par
qui ? Déjà par nos importations. Il faut
payer les importations. Donc les
importations c'est 35 points. Ces 35
points et derrière les services et le
commerce 40 %. Donc c'est l'aval qui
gagne aujourd'hui sur ceux qui
travaillent. Et on peut se poser la
question de notre sécurité alimentaire
qu'en moins d'un quart de la valeur
ajoutée est touché par ceux qui
travaillent, c'est-à-dire les
agriculteurs et les industries
agroalimentaires. Petite ou grande ?
Ouais.
À la fin, c'est toujours une question
d'argent.
Ouais.
C'est une phrase du film.
C'est c'est un un des personnages
centrals du film qui dit ça à la fin du
film. Ouais. Et bah oui, de toute façon,
c'est pas nouveau ça. Enfin, j'ai rien
inventé en disant ça, mais quand on
rentre dans ce monde là,
comment s'appelle l'acteur qui dit ça ?
Il s'appelle Olivier Gourmet.
Extraordinaire.
Ouais, c'est un super acteur. Il est il
est parfait dans dans ce rôle du requin
tueur justement. Et oui, bah for
il aime les les croissants congelés.
Il aime les croissants surgelés. Ouais.
Ouais. C'est parce que c'est un
personnage. Bon après voilà, moi je fais
du cinéma donc aussi ce qui là toutes
ces discussions m'ont moi m'ont fasciné
mais ce qui m'a intéressé aussi c'est de
c'est de traiter le les personnages dans
ce monde là. En fait, j'essaie dans mon
film de montrer comment fonctionne ce
système, mais c'est pas non plus un
documentaire, mais j'essaie surtout en
fait de voir comment des êtres humains
évolue dans ce système- là. Il y en a
qui veulent le combattre, il y en a qui
veulent le faire changer, il y en a qui
veulent le perpétuer parce qu'ils en
profitent. Et donc c'est c'est toutes
ces choses-là qui m'ont
en terme d'empathie, tu as laissé des
plumes.
Moi personnellement, il y a des choses
qui m'ont euh
qui m'ont vraiment questionné. Tu vois
ce que je te disais tout à l'heure sur
la première phrase que j'ai entendu là,
les fameux requins tueurs quand j'étais
dans ce séminaire. La première question
qui m'est venue, c'est les gens qui sont
là et qui entendent ça et à qui c'est
destiné, qu'est-ce qu'ils se disent dans
leur tête ? Est-ce que il ils se disent
bah oui, il faut qu'on soit des requins
tueurs et tout. Est-ce qu'ils se disent
"Non mais qu'est-ce que je fous là ?" et
non, moi je veux pas de ça. Est-ce
qu'ils se disent c'est du folklore ?
Est-ce que vraiment j'avais envie
d'essayer de me mettre à la place de ces
gens-là pour comprendre ce qui pouvait
les motiver à croire à ce discours, à
mettre en place ces choses-là ? Et donc
j'ai essayé de de comprendre ça et j'ai
eu des des discussions avec une
acheteuse notamment en poste qui m'a dit
des trucs et j'ai eu de l'empathie pour
elle.
Elle m'a dit voilà
moi dans mon poste d'acheteuse donc
pendant les fameuses négociations là qui
durent 3 mois j'ai essayé de défendre
des PME parce que je pensais que c'était
une bonne chose de les mettre en avant
de leur donner une place ainsi de suite.
Et puis jusqu'au dernier jour des
négociations, je pensais vraiment qu'on
allait pouvoir signer ce contrat et puis
au dernier moment bah mon boss est venu
me voir et m'a dit bah ça y est on a
bien fait le boulot avec le lièvre et
donc maintenant on va l'assassiner. Donc
en fait, on va pas aller au bout avec
cette PME et parce que justement le
leader a baissé ses prix ou a revu ses
position du fait que on l'a mis en
danger en poussant un challenger et donc
elle m'a dit voilà le dernier jour j'ai
dû assassiner c'est ces termes cette PME
et là je lui dis mais comment on vit
avec ça ? Enfin je veux dire vous la
nuit comment ça se passe ? Et donc elle
me dit justement quand je lui dis
comment on vit avec ça, elle me dit bah
moi j'ai pas dormi de la nuit derrière
et je me j'avais du mal à me regarder
dans la glace mais en même temps c'est
mon boulot et donc je continue quoi. Et
en fait
ça c'est un truc qui m'a qui m'a marqué
parce que j'ai le sentiment que ce
système il dépasse tout le monde.
C'est-à-dire que les agriculteurs en
sont les victimes. tel que vient de le
raconter Olivier. Les industriels à leur
niveau aussi, ils en souffrent, ils s'en
sont mécontentants, ils s'en plaignent.
Les grands distributeurs, il renvoient
la balle aux autres. Mais les gens qui
sont là-dedans, même les acheteurs qui
pratiquent ces choses-là, moi je ne peux
pas croire que ces gens-là soient
épanouis à fonctionner dans un système
où le but est d'extorquer de la marge,
de mettre de la pression psychologique.
Extorquer ou gagner.
Ouais, mais bon, apparemment, c'est
extorqué.
Le champ lexical est important.
Apparemment, c'est extorqué. En tout
cas, c'est ce qu'il m'a dit et d'après
ce qu' ce qu'il m'a dit, c'est ce qu'on
essaie de leur mettre dans le logiciel.
Et d'ailleurs, pour revenir à cette
fameuse expérience que j'ai eu dans le
séminaire, au-delà des requins tueurs,
j'ai aussi eu des phrases du type
si votre fournisseur sort de la de la
négociation satisfait de sa négociation,
c'est qu'il y a un problème, c'est que
vous l'avez pas assez rincé. le win win,
ça n'existe pas dans notre monde. Enfin,
c'était des choses comme ça. Donc, on
est plus dans un langage guerrier ou
d'extorsion que dans un légage dans un
langage de jeu où on essaie de défendre
ses intérêts et de gagner la partie.
Dans le film, il y a il y a il y a
quelque chose qui m'a qui m'a marqué,
c'est ce fameux requin tueur.
Ouais.
Le le le gros carcarodon carcarias dit
euh à ça son bébé requin, toi toi tu es
là pour faire baisser les prix.
Ouais. Parce que 90 % des gens qui
rentrent dans nos supermarchés gagnent
1300 € par mois et que on est là pour
50 %
ça pardon 50 % gagne 1300 € par mois
1500 € par mois ou
1500 € par mois merci
ou moins de 1500 € par mois
moins de et on est là aussi pour qu'il
bouffe bien et qu'il bouffe des trucs
bons pour pas trop cher
bah ouais et alors tu tu as cru à ça ou
pas
c'est toi qui l'a mis dans le film
ouais mais je te demande est-ce que tu y
crois
et lui il y croyait ou pas ? Ben, c'est
toute la question, c'est et elle est
elle est centrale cette question. Est-ce
qu'ils y croient ? Est-ce que c'est un
argument marketing ? Est-ce que moi
c'est une question aussi que je me suis
posée parce que ça part d'un bon
sentiment de se dire euh on est là pour
défendre le pouvoir d'achat des Français
parce que c'est ça euh l'argument que
nous rabâche la grande distribution. Il
presque ils sont en mission même si on
écoute leur leur discours, si on voit la
façon dont ils communiquent, les slogans
même qu'ils ont depuis des années, on a
l'impression qu'en fait ils sauvent
sauvent la France. Euh en tout cas, il
ils travaillent pour le pouvoir d'achat
des Français.
Ça leur donne ça leur donne euh des
moyens de pression parce qu'il y a une
scène du film où ils vont dans un
ministère. Ouais.
Ça leur donne euh on rebondit sur ton
acolyte juste à côté. Ça leur donne du
pouvoir auprès du ministère parce que
comme ils sont détenteurs aussi d'une
partie du pouvoir d'achat des Français,
ils sont aussi détenteurs d'une partie
de la révolte des Français.
Alors révolte des Français qui ne
comprennent pas toujours finalement la
pièce que certains distributeurs leur
jouent. C'est-à-dire que quand on
dispose effectivement de budgets
colossaux, des centaines de millions
d'euros dépensés en communication, les
combien vous gagnez vous ?
Moi moi aujourd'hui ouais je gagne 3800
€ par mois.
Net, brut,
net,
il a de la chance.
Donc au-delà du revenu médian, le revenu
médian en fin de compte c'est 2200 €. 50
% en plus, 50 % en moins en France. Et
depuis des années, et rappelez-vous en
1949,
les premiers pas d'Édouard Lecler à
Landerneau, c'était cette logique
d'acheter moins cher pour essayer de
vendre pas cher. Sauf que les Français
se trompent aujourd'hui. Les
distributeurs, ils achètent moins cher
et ils vendent plus cher. Ce n'est plus
la promesse initiale. C'est-à-dire que
c'est sourcé ça.
Mais bien entendu que c'est sourcé parce
que avec mes étudiants au sein de mon
master euh j'adore effectivement les
amener dans les magasins. et leur dit
vous achetez votre viande hachée. Les
jeunes adorent les burgers, adorent ça.
Donc résultat, la viande hachée chez
chez les jeunes dans la génération Z,
moins de 35 ans, ils adorent ça. Mais au
bout du compte derrière, qu'est-ce qui
se passe ? Il se passe que quand on fait
des relevés en Bretagne aujourd'hui, on
s'aperçoit que le steak haché est en
gros entre 18 et 19,50 € du kilo quand
chez les artisans bouchés.
Combien de matières grasse ? Combien de
matière grasse dans le steck acheté à ce
prix-là ?
Et ben généralement 15 %. Et au bout du
compte derrière, on s'aperçoit que chez
les bouchers artisans, le le steak haché
de 3 € moins cher. Vérifie encore là sur
le bassin d'Arcachon. Et donc en fait
les Français ont une image qui est
mauvaise parce que chez moi, je dis
toujours, c'est le coco de Pintul qui
finance le Coca d'Atlanta. C'est le
chou-fleur de Saint-Paul qui finance le
Coca d'Atlanta. Ça veut dire quoi
par rapport aux pensions de retraite.
Par rapport aux pensions de retraite,
non, mais simplement par rapport à une
chose qui est toute simple, c'est que
aujourd'hui le distributeur, sa part de
marché est définie par son image prix.
Et donc le fait d'avoir une image prix
et cette image prix qui soit aussi
pertinente, il la travaille à travers
ses budgets comme ces centaines de
millions déversés mais la permanence de
son image prix lui permet d'avoir une
part de marché qui augmente. Et donc
aujourd'hui, trois enseignes ont
particulièrement réussi à faire passer
cette image de discounter. Mais quand on
y regarde de plus près, aujourd'hui, on
vend du Coca à ce qu'on appelle au seuil
de revente à perte plus 10 %, c'est la
loi
du colat
du colat du colat à SRP + 10 %. Mais au
bout du compte derrière, pour gagner
leur vie, les distributeurs ont besoin
de bien plus de 10 % de marge. Ils ont
besoin de 35 à 40 points. Et donc, ils
vont trouver d'autres produits, les
produits de nos terroirs, ceux qui
construisent finalement notre socle
aussi d'emploi en région. Et c'est ces
produits qui vont supporter des
coefficients incroyables. Euh on peut
donner un exemple, un chou-fleur
aujourd'hui, un chou-fleur cet hiver, un
chou-fleur qui était vendu au marché au
cadrant 30 centimes plus les coûts
logistiques, 50 centimes mais qui se
retrouve à 3,50 voire à 4 € à Paris.
Mais quel est le sens économique à cela
? Ça veut dire que le producteur lui, il
ne gagnerait sa vie à 80 centimes. 1 €
le chou-fleur il gagne sa vie. On lui
refuse ce prix. Par contre d'autres
utilisent des multiplicateurs x 4 x 5 x
6 pour gagner leur vie sur ce
chou-fleur. Et c'est la même chose sur
des obios. J'expliquais dernièrement que
des bios vendus à 45 centimes mais que
le producteur n'en touche que 15 ou 16
mais que derrière effectivement il y a
pas beaucoup de transformation dans un
œuf bio. Mais quelque part certains
s'arrangent pour effectivement prendre
les multiplicateurs qui ne prennent pas
sur le colat.
Tu as vu ça toi dans ton film ?
Les chouffleurs ?
Ouais.
Non non. Bah ce qu' ce qu'il dit là, on
me l'a raconté. Donc moi je suis j'ai
pas son expertise, je rentre pas sur les
marchés.
Tu as eu des pressions quand tu as fait
?
Non, j'ai eu aucune pression.
Quand tu as été sondé des supermarchés,
des centrales d'achat, quand tu as été
voir les gens ?
Non, j'ai eu aucune pression. Je me suis
heurté par contre à une omerta, ça c'est
sûr. J'ai été confronté à du silence.
C'est-à-dire que au début moi naïvement,
j'ai commencé à contacter des gens. La
plupart ne me répondait pas. Alors, si
on prend les gens de la grande
distribution, bah ça paraît un peu
logique. Ils ont pas envie quelqu'un
foursonner là-dedans. Euh,
tu contacté système ? J'ai contacté à
peu près euh en fait ce que j'ai fait,
j'ai fait une chose un travail de
fourmis euh vraiment basique quoi,
concret de terrain. J'ai je suis allé
sur euh une plateforme, un réseau social
professionnel euh vous voyez dequel je
parle peut-être, je peux le lire.
Celui qui se fait manger par euh
l'intelligence artificielle. Ah
ils sont tous un peu mangés.
Ça commence par un L.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Et ça finit par leing par N. Voilà,
c'est ça. Donc bon, voilà, je suis allé
là-dessus et j'ai fait des des des
recherches, je tapé acheteur grand
distribution, tout ça. Puis il y a des
des des dizaines et des dizaines de noms
qui me sont sortis. Puis j'ai un peu
regardé ceux que je voulais contacter.
J'ai envoyé des messages. Bon, il y en a
qui qui m'ont répondu quand même en
disant "Non, je veux pas parler et
tout." Et puis il y en a certains qui
m'ont répondu, qui m'ont j'ai gagné leur
confiance, ils m'ont donné un numéro de
téléphone, je les ai appelé et tous ces
gens-là, tous ces gens à qui j'ai parlé
m'ont tous dit "Euh, déjà vous êtes qui
? Qu'est-ce que vous allez faire ?
Surtout, vous parlez pas de moi, vous
donnez pas mon nom. Il a fallu que je
gagne le leur confiance et j'en ai
quelques-uns qui ont accepté de de me
parler." Donc ça c'est déjà côté
distribution. Mais après, je suis aussi
allé voir, et ça c'était encore pire les
industriels et je suis allé voir des
petites PME françaises que j'ai essayé
de contacté parce que j'avais vu dans
les médias que il y avait des choses qui
étaient sorties sur certaines
entreprises qui avaient été mises en
difficulté par la grande distribution.
Donc j'ai essayé de les contacter. Là,
je suis tombé sur des gens qui étaient
mais une défiance terrible et qui se
demandaient si j'étais pas journaliste,
si j'allais pas euh si j'allais pas
parler de ce ce cas-là. Euh j'ai une
personne qui m'a dit, je cite pas son
nom hein, parce qu'il il veut bien sûr
être anonyme, que lui avait pris la
parole dans les médias et a été convoqué
euh quelques jours après par une par une
enseigne qui lui a fait passer un très
mauvais quart d'heure parce qu'il avait
parlé dans la dans la presse et qu'il
l'a menacé de le sortir de ses magasins
et ainsi de suite. Donc il y a des
représailles qui font que ces gensl ne
veulent pas parler parce qu'ils ont peur
en fait de perdre 20 à 25 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires. Olivier, je te vois
d'autres ligés de la tête. Pourquoi ?
Oui, parce qu'en fait c'est tout à fait
ça aujourd'hui. C'est-à-dire que la
pression elle est là et la pression est
d'autant plus forte aujourd'hui que le
contexte économique est très tendu.
C'estàd que les tensions géopolitiques
ont cristallisé les négociations
commerciales 2026. Parce que
rappelons-nous 2022 quand Vladimir sort
des frontières russes, aussitôt on va
dire l'inflation comme une grippe
espagnole s'introduit dans notre
économie et l'inflation elle s'introduit
toujours par trois facteurs. L'énergie
auprès des deux populations qui ont le
plus besoin d'énergie, la pêche et
l'agriculture. Et très vite, quelques
mois après, les produits frais étaient à
la hausse parce que les produits frais
sont ceux qui augmentent le plus vite.
et puis petit à petit se sont transmis
au sec, à l'épicerie et au surgelé enfin
derrière. Et quand on voit les Français
qui ont subi des hauses de près de 20 à
25 % sur leur alimentaire, là la
situation est critique parce que ce qui
se passe actuellement aujourd'hui dans
le D3 d'Ormous est en train à nouveau de
ramener un second tour inflationniste
alors même que le pouvoir d'achat des
Français n'a jamais été aussi éloigné de
leur vouloir d'achat. Et ça, je veux
dire, je sors un peu de mon domaine,
l'économie pure parce que finalement
c'est de la société mais on sait tous
nous que quand le vouloir d'achat et le
pouvoir d'achat sont aussi éloigné, cela
annonce effectivement des lendemains qui
déchantent. Cela annonce des tensions
sociales très importantes aussi bien
chez les boomers que dans les que chez
les jeunes génération. Et le deuxième
tour inflationniste que l'on voit est un
deuxième tour qui va amener à nouveau 10
15 20 % de hausse de l'alimentaire. Et
le problème sur les chiffres que l'on a
dit avec aujourd'hui 30 % de la
population qui vit au seuil de pauvreté
parce que je rappelle que 100 millions
de personnes en France sont en précarité
alimentaire, en précarité financière et
en précarité immobilière. C'est-à-dire
que 10 millions de personnes aujourd'hui
vont se retrouver avec une part de
l'alimentaire en hausse très sensible
dans sur par rapport à leur revenus. Et
donc ils ne vont pas pouvoir faire ce
second tour parce que on voit très bien
aujourd'hui les ventes aujourd'hui dans
de l'alimentaire ne sont pas revenues au
niveau de la crise de 2022. Et donc on
voit très bien à quel point la classe
moyenne, c'est-à-dire nous on divise
tout en décil. Les 31 millions de
foyers, on les divise en tranche de
3100000. Donc les 9 millions qui ont des
problèmes. Et après la classe moyenne.
Et cette classe moyenne aujourd'hui
c'est 50 % des personnes des gens qui
ont besoin absolument aujourd'hui de
prix parce que ils voient leurs dépenses
préengagées exploser. Et les dépenses
préengagées, c'est ce qu'on paye tous en
début de mois. Et après, il y a un reste
à vivre. Mais le problème de ce que ce
reste à vivre, il diminue de plus en
plus. Et les distributeurs sont là
confrontés à une situation où ce reste à
vivre est très disputé entre eux. Et
donc, c'est cette guerre qui se livre
pour les prix bas que le film
retranscrit très bien.
Le film, comment tu as fait pour
retranscrire tous ces prix bas ?
Ben justement, pas par mon enquête, moi
j'ai rien inventé. Je suis allé chercher
des gens comme lui qui m'ont expliqué.
Il y a un autre une autre personne que
j'aimerais citer qui m'a aidé qui
s'appelle Marwan Mary. Je sais pas si si
ça te parle mais il a fait quelques
apparitions dans le dans les médias dans
des
Il est psychologue.
Il est pas psychologue mais il
s'intéresse en effet à la psy à la
psychologie de la négociation.
Il est libanais.
Il est d'origine en
Ouais je l'ai eu au téléphone il est
super sympa.
Ouais il est d'origine libanaise je
crois mais je j'en suis pas sûr mais en
tout cas c'est possible. Ouais et en
tout cas il a une histoire un peu avec
le avec le Liban. Ouais. Donc Marwan,
c'est c'est pareil, je l'ai appelé au
moment de mon enquête parce que j'avais
vu qu'il était bien implanté dans ses
négociations. En fait, c'est un ancien
compte clé. Alors, pour ceux qui
connaissent pas ce milieu-là, les
comptes clés en fait, c'est des
commerciaux pour les industriels qui
participent aux négociations et donc qui
vont aller dans les fameux box, négocier
avec les acheteurs. Et donc, c'est un
ancien compte clé qui s'est reconverti
et qui a lancé un cabinet de conseil en
négociation avec un ancien du RAID et
donc il est très axé justement sur la
psychologie des négociations ainsi de
suite. Et quand je lui ai parlé, il m'a
expliqué, il m'a dit "Bah c'est très
bien que tu essayes de faire un film
là-dessus. Bon, déjà, je pense que tu y
arriveras pas parce que c'est trop
compliqué." Mais je crois qu'Olivier
m'avait dit aussi la même chose quand je
l'ai rencontré. Et lui il s'intéresse
justement à la psychologie des choses et
il m'a dit "Tu sais euh il y a un truc
sur sur lequel je suis en train de
travailler, c'est les psychopathes."
Et donc mais il me dit "Mais pas les
psychopathes
tels qu'on on on
en entreprise
les psychopathes au sens médical du
terme en fait. C'est-à-dire, il y a sep
critères, alors je les ai plus tous en
tête, mais il y a l'absence d'empathie,
le manque de remord, le fait de ne
jamais avoir de culpabilité, le fait de
je sais plus de de se sentir au-dessus
des des règles et des lois, le fait de
ne pas gérer la frustration. Bon voilà,
je vous en ai déjà donné presque sep
finalement. Et donc il m'a dit voilà
généralement dans la population
française il y a enfin mondial même il y
a 1 % de psychopathes et il me disait
plus on monte dans la hiérarchie plus on
trouve de psychopath et lui il me disait
dans les fameuses négociation moi mes
observations c'est qu'il y a 30 % de
psychopathes chez les acheteurs de la
grande distribution.
Il est pas psychiatre ?
Non non il est pas psychiatre mais il a
je pense qu'il a écrit à l'époque moi où
je lui ai parlé il écrivait un bouquin
sur le sujet il est documenté. Enfin, je
dire c'est pas un charlatan. Euh il et
donc il me disait ça et euh et il me dit
"Bon euh
en fait si les Français savaient ce qui
se passait dans les boxes de
négociation, il boycotterait certaines
enseignes, ce que lui d'ailleurs fait,
ce que je suis pas loin de faire avec
certaines enseignes aussi depuis que
j'ai fait ce film.
Donc
franchement, tout ce que j'ai recueilli,
c'est une matière. Pourquoi on faire un
film ? parce que c'est c'est une matière
où il y a tout pour faire un film.
C'est-à-dire que il y a comme je te
disais tout à l'heure, il y a déjà ce
lieu des boxes de négociation très
anxiogène où il y a de la tension où il
y a a y a il y a il y a potentiellement
de la de la pression psychologique. Moi,
j'adore les thrillers donc j'ai décidé
aussi d'en faire un thriller. Mais il y
a aussi des enjeux des personnages avec
des enjeux de survie. Euh il y a euh
c'est euh c'est un endroit le box de
négociation mais euh voilà Olivier en
parle mieux que moi, mais où se joue des
enjeux colossaux de pouvoir d'achat, de
qualité euh des aliments, de revenus
agricoles.
Pour toutes ces raisons, je me suis
lancé je me suis lancé là-dedans et j'ai
essayé à ma manière de retranscrire les
choses pour revenir à cette guerre des
PRIBas de la façon la plus exigeante
possible parce que je suis un outsider,
moi je suis pas de ce milieu-là, j'ai
jamais fait des négociations, je suis
pas rentré dedans. Mais je me suis dit
si je traite ce sujet, il faut que je le
fasse vraiment avec beaucoup
d'exigences, que je rencontre plein de
gens, que je me documente. C'est pas un
documentaire mais c'est une fiction qui
est documentée. Et depuis que le film
est sorti, même avant parce que j'ai
fait une tournée d'avant-première, je me
suis confronté au public et il s'avère
que dans les avant-première, bah le
sujet il intéresse les gens directement
concernés. Donc j'ai eu des
agriculteurs, j'ai eu des acheteurs,
j'ai eu des industriels et tous m'ont
dit "En fait merci de montrer cette
réalité." Mais même les gens qui sont
qui font partie de la de la grande
distribution, j'ai eu une ancienne
acheteuse qui s'est levée à la fin de la
projection en disant je dois vous avouer
que en fait le là ce que vous avez
montré à l'écran, moi je l'ai fait et
j'en suis pas fier. Et d'ailleurs,
depuis j'ai démissionné et je suis allé
au salon de l'agriculture. J'ai croisé
mes je ne sais plus combien de gens dans
cette journée qui m'ont dit "Mais
personne peut parler de ça, on peut pas
parler de ça mais tout le monde sait que
ça se passe comme ça. Merci de le
montrer." Donc moi, je suis pas je suis
pas je suis pas un militant. Je suis pas
là pour faire un film qui
diabolise la grande distribution ou
quelqu'un. Je suis pas en mission quoi.
Je suis juste un citoyen déjà qui s'est
intéressé à ce sujet-là,
un cinéaste qui a voulu s'en emparer,
qui l'a dramatisé, qui en a fait un
film. Mais en fait, tout ce que j'ai
découvert m'a profondément touché,
marqué et je ne comprends pas et encore
aujourd'hui, je ne comprends pas
pourquoi ce sujet-là ne prend pas plus
de place en fait dans la société, dans
l'actualité.
Oui. Et pourquoi il comprend pas ?
Il faut comprendre d'où vient la grande
distribution. C'est-à-dire que quand la
grande distribution se lance dans les
années 60, il y a 900000 petits
commerçants en France à ce moment-là. En
73, c'est-à-dire donc 13 ans plus tard,
les petits commerçants iront chercher
Jean Royer, un député qui fera voter une
loi le 27 décembre 73, une loi contre la
grande distribution. ce sera la première
loi contre la grande distribution parce
qu'on a divisé par deux la population de
petits commerçants en l'espace d'une
dizaine d'années. La grande on change de
monde effectivement le petit commerce
souffre devant l'avancée de la grande
distribution. Cette grande distribution
est là il y a chaque maire est sous
pression. Chacun veut son supermarché,
voir son hypermarché dans les ceintures
des villes. Et là, effectivement, il y
aura du financement de partis politiques
à cette époque avant la loi de
moralisation du parti politique de
Lionel Jospin. Feu Lionel Jospin
aujourd'hui effectivement. Et donc à
partir de là, elle ne va plus s'arrêter
et chacun des présidents, chacun des
magistrats qui auront en charge la
conduite de ce pays va avoir la grande
distribution à partir de là. Et donc les
lois vont se succéder et certaines sont
plus marquantes que d'autres. Et Jacques
Chirac va se retrouver lui lors de sa
campagne en 95 avec des industriels qui
lui disent "Monsieur Shirac, ce n'est
plus possible. Ce n'est plus possible
parce que les distributeurs aujourd'hui
et ben ils prennent la majorité de la
valeur ajoutée. Il nous reste pas
grand-chose. Les petits commerçants
viennent lui dire "Monsieur Chirac, si
vous êtes élu, ferez quelque chose pour
nous parce que nous on va disparaître."
Ce seront les lois Galant et les lois
Rafarin du 1er juillet 96 et du 5
juillet 96. Lois qui vont être encore
contre la grande distribution. Et donc
ces lois n'auront pas les effets
escomptés. Elles vont créer des systèmes
de marge arrière. Et quand Nicolas
Sarkozi arrive au pouvoir en 2007, il se
retrouve lui aussi avec ce problème-là.
C'est-à-dire que les lois Galant et les
lois Rafarin ont entraîné la hausse des
marges arrières de manière incroyable.
C'est-à-dire que sur une boîte de cage
par exemple, 80 % du prix du cage, c'est
de la marge arrière. Où est la cohérence
économique à cela ? Il y en a aucune. La
France est devenue en 2008 le pays où
l'alimentaire est le plus cher. À partir
de là, il faut faire quelque chose
source
et ben c'est tout simplement la
commission Atali. Commission Atali où le
secrétaire général de la commission
Atali était monsieur Emmanuel Macron. Et
donc dans cette commission Atalie, cette
commission Atali a préparé la grande loi
sur lequelle nous vivons tous le
commerce, la loi du 4 août 2008 dite loi
de modernisation de l'économie. Cette
loi de modernisation de l'économie,
l'économie va être donc soutenue par
Christine Lagarde qui est la ministre
d'économie des finances de Nicolas
Sarkozi. Et donc cette loi va venir
crever le système des marges arrières et
on va repasser dans un système dit
avant. C'est-à-dire que le distributeur
qui a perdu pendant 12 ans la capacité à
négocier les prix la retrouve tout d'un
coup. Et donc la violence commerciale va
la s'installer et puis il y a une
enseigne en particulier qui va à ce
moment-là comprendre mieux les enjeux et
comprendre mieux les portées de la loi.
C'est le groupe Lecler. Le groupe
Leclerc qui en 2009 pèse 16 % de part de
marché, c'est-à-dire 9 points de moins
qu'aujourd'hui. Mais le groupe Leclerc
va enchaîner 180 mois, 15 ans, 15 ans de
croissance ininterrompue de sa part de
marché sans qu'aucun autre distributeur
ne puisse la lui contester. Pourquoi ?
parce qu'il va comprendre vite que dans
le fond ces négociations, elles doivent
être violentes sous couvert de cette
loi. Et donc les
vous avez des preuves que c'est violent
leur négociation ou par
et ben en fait on on voit on voit la
violence tout simplement quand on
regarde parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
panels qui comparent les prix eaux et
vous voyez cette course à l'échalotte
c'est-à-dire toujours le même premier le
groupe Lecler
c'est ils sont peut-être plus sympas ils
ont peut-être plus de distribution on
peut aussi croire au père Noël mais moi
je ne crois pas au père Noël crois
au père Noël moi. Et donc quand on
achète un prix,
quand on achète un prix, il y a il y a
trois possibilités. Soit vous négociez
avec le Colatas, soit n vous négociez le
Colatas. Et dans ces cas-là, que vous
soyez Carrefour, que vous soyez
Intermarché U ou Leclerc, vous pesez à
peine 06 08 % de la part de marché
mondial chez Cola. À partir de là,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Il se passe que
là et ben d'un côté, il y a un rapport
de force qui s'équilibre.
Mais dès qu'il s'agit d'entreprise plus
petites et qu'on quitte les
multinationales pour venir sur les
coopératives agricoles ou pour venir sur
des ETI, des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire, à partir de là
effectivement bah c'est beaucoup plus
violent. C'est-à-dire que
j'aimerais comprendre beaucoup plus
violent dans quel sens beaucoup violent
plus de négociation.
Vous arrivez pour vendre un produit et
vous dites "Ce produit je le vends à 5
€."
Les distributeurs chercheront toujours à
l'avoir le moins cher possible. Pourquoi
? Parce que c'est indispensable pour eux
que de pouvoir avoir cette image des
prix bas. Et cette image des prix bas
derrière, elle crée la part de marché.
Et s'il y a pas de part de marché, les
actionnaires ne suivent pas et on rentre
pas l'argent en grande distribution.
C'est le volume qui fait derrière
effectivement l'argent parce qu'on y
viendra peut-être aussi dans le fond
derrière ce système est mis en place
pour rémunérer pour rémunérer ceux qui
sont propriétaires de ces enseignes.
Je vais défendre Michelard,
il est peut-être plus sympa, il a
peut-être plus de distribution comme il
a plus de de de points de distribution,
on lui fait des meilleurs prix et ça se
passe ça se passe très bien sur
sa bonne mine sur sa bonne mine.
Il a une bonne mine
sur sa bonne mine. Mais pourquoi
pourquoi le groupe Lecler aujourd'hui
est meilleur que les autres ? Parce que
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils
dominent les autres de la tête et des
épaules. C'est parce que ils se sont
organisés en 16 centrales d'achat
régional qui sont toutes réparties selon
finalement un petit peu les vieilles
cartes géographiques qu'on avait en CM2
dans les classes de primaire,
c'est-à-dire la Bretagne, la Normandie
l'enjou. On a eu un redécoupage
administratif par Hollande
en 16 régions. Le groupe du du Méloir,
c'est Anger.
À partir de là, quand on regarde bien
les choses, on va dire que il y a
adéquation entre l'offre que ces
centrales d'achat régional proposent à
des milliers de consommateurs en région
et de l'autre côté finalement la
capacité qu'a groupe à négocier ces
produits pour eux. Et donc aujourd'hui,
regardez, le distributeur le plus en
forme, il a 16 centrales d'achat
régional. Le deuxième qui va très bien
aussi, le groupe Intermarché, on a H. Le
groupe Système U, on a quatre. Et tous
ceux qui sont en difficulté, Carrefour,
Auchamp, Casino et on parlera peut-être
de l'idol et Aldia à un autre moment,
ils n'ont qu'une centrale d'achat
national. C'est-à-dire que il faut
reconnaître au gros lecler la cohérence
économique qu'ils ont aujourd'hui. Ils
sont organisés, ils sont taillés pour la
course, ils sont reptiliens. Et Michel
Eddouard Leclerc est reptilien.
Reptilien, c'est-à-dire que quelqu'un il
y a pas d'éthanam, il y a pas d'émotion.
Euh c'est aussi une moi, je je vais me
faire l'avocat de Michel Loir. Bah, ils
en ont 16 connectés en région. Ils
connaissent leurs pays, ils connaissent
leur terroir. Les gens viennent plus
facilement chez eux.
Voilà. Et oui et tout et tout tout irait
pour le mieux dans le meilleur des
mondes si dans le fond le groupe Lecler
n'agissait enfin n'était pas comme une
jetée devant la marée. C'est-à-dire
qu'elle empêche la marée de monter et
tout le temps elle dit bah non les
augmentations tarifaires, il y en a pas.
Parce que il faut bien comprendre que la
loi pour comprendre la construction du
prix la construction du prix c'est un
rapport de force mais dans un cadre
législatif donné. Et ce cadre législatif
aujourd'hui, il amène en fait le
distributeur chaque année envoyant un
recommandé à l'industriel en lui disant
"Je dénonce les conditions générales de
vente de l'année dernière. C'est
terminé, on doit reprendre des
négociations." Et donc qu'est-ce que va
faire l'industriel ? Il lui renvoie des
conditions générales de vente et ensuite
l'industriel attend près de son
téléphone que le distributeur l'appelle
et souvent l'appel ne vient pas. Alors
l'industriel appelle et puis il est
reçu. Mais plus vous êtes un
distributeur puissant et plus vous
tardez à appeler parce que si vous
voulez un produit parce que des fois le
distributeur il y a d'excellents
produits locaux tout le monde connaît la
mode du local aujourd'hui et le groupe
Lecler a beaucoup de local en linéaire
et donc quand vous voulez du local ben
quelque part vous allez vous organiser
pour l'avoir mais au meilleur prix parce
que vous ferez une meilleure marge
aussi. Et donc dans le fond, les autres,
c'est-à-dire les intégrés les carrefour
au champ euh géant casino aujourd'hui
court après un lapin mécanique. Et donc
je concède qu'effectivement euh le
groupe Leclerc est très bon sur sa
cohérence économique mais qu'à côté de
ça, son attitude à vouloir les prix les
plus bas enchaîne sur notre souveraineté
alimentaire et est en train d'éroder
notre socle agricole.
Vous avez discuté de ça avec eux ? Alors
oui, avec certains d'entre eux et je
reconnais que il y a deux enseignes en
particulier avec qui on peut discuter
qui sont Intermarché et Systemme et donc
j'ai on passe le bonjour à Dominique.
Ouais. à Dominiqueur. Oui. Et à Thierry
Cotillard aussi
et effectivement et avec eux avec eux
j'échange plus parce que dans le fond
ils comprennent une chose, je leur dis
tout le temps dans la niche du prix il y
a un chien. Ce chien aujourd'hui c'est
Michel Édouard Leclerc et chaque fois
que vous êtes en train de mettre la main
on peut pas continuer à Michel on peut
pas le le comparer à un chien. C'est pas
un chien mais il est dans sa niche du
prix et chaque fois que Dominique ou
Thierry veulent mettre la main dans la
niche du prix, il les mort. Et ce qui
est intéressant, c'est qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une image que vous
c'est une image.
Merci.
Mais il est il est mort. Il est mort
parce que quelque part derrière il
rabaisse en prix, il remet la promo, il
remet encore plus bas et donc il est
dans cette logique là. Et donc
aujourd'hui, ce qui est intéressant,
c'est de trouver U et Intermarché qui
cherchent de la cohérence ailleurs.
C'est-à-dire que ils cherchent de la
transparence, ils cherchent à avoir des
marques de distributeurs, donc les
produits des enseignes he de grande
distribution avec plus de transparence,
plus d'origine France. Il cherche à
monter des accords tripartites dans
lequels le distributeur essaie de peser
du bon côté parce que le distributeur
peut avoir un bon côté. Et Michel Birot
quand il était directeur des achats chez
Lidl a montré la voix à tout le monde.
lui utilisait sa puissance pour dire au
groupe Bigar voilà là est une
organisation de producteur de port
abattre ses ports vous Bigar et vous
allez payer ses ports à ce prix et le
contrat était dit de tripartite c'est
que le distributeur engage sa puissance
pour assurer au monde agricole un revenu
mais évidemment certaines enseignes ne
il fait ça aussi non
le contrat tripartite ah c'est pas son
truc non c'est c'est plutôt le contrat
dual C'est-à-dire si tu veux être chez
moi et ben tu me vends au prix auquel je
souhaite que tu me vendes et dans les
volumes que je te dis. Et donc
aujourd'hui euh
ça ça c'est vous avez c'est de sources
sûr ? Ben bien sûr, mais bien sûr. Mais
on on verra si on est contredit, mais
euh mon audition euh devant la
commission d'enquête parlementaire est
en audition libre, hein. Tout le monde
sur le site du Sénat peut la retrouver
et euh je ne suis pas le seul euh à le
dire effectivement, mais ce qui est
certain, c'est que on doit absolument
penser qu'il y a trois sécurités, trois
souverainetés qui sont non négociables
dans ce pays. C'est la militaire,
l'énergétique et l'alimentaire. On doit
absolument là-dessus se dire que ce sont
des fondamentaux. Et donc euh je rejoins
Anthony en disant "Je suis très étonné
de voir à quel point effectivement la
sécurité énergétique et la sécurité
militaire sont une obsession naturelle
dans le contexte que l'on connaît.
Mais l'alimentaire non."
Non mais côté énergie, vous avez pas
suivi un petit peu la girgouette sur le
nucléaire ? Si,
donc il y connaissaient rien.
Mais si, parce que quelque part, je vais
souvent à à Bruxelles euh à la DG euh
concurrence ou à la DG santé et j'écoute
euh mes pères, d'autres profs
d'université européens et il y a un prof
d'université euh italien de la Cogne à
Milan qui disait "Dans le fond, pourquoi
la France n'est pas l'Arabie Saoudite de
l'électricité en Europe ? avec vos 56
centrales d'
on va dire et votre nouveau réacteur,
vos centrales nucléaires à plein régime
57 maintenant ou 58, vous seriez comme
les Norvégiens avec un fond souverain
qui aurait permis effectivement à la
France de se désendeter.
Et effectivement,
on n' pas non plus toujours suivi cette
logique de cette sécurité
électrique comme on aurait pu avoir.
Parce que je rappelle à un moment donné,
à un moment donné, on peut se dire aussi
que j'entends encore mon grand-père me
dire "Ah, la France, elle est quand même
dirigée par des polytechniciens." Oui,
effectivement
Pompidou, Valérie Giscardestin,
Raisember
voilà avait une vision de la France et
puis on l'a perdu un peu et on l'a perdu
dans l'énergétique et on a bien vu
comment n nos présidents pour des
raisons politiques face effectivement à
des partis politiques qui font commerce
de leur vote en écologie qu'il fallait
effectivement ne pas ben finalement
entretenir telle ou telle centrale pour
donner plus ou moins raison à tel ou
telle partie et au bout du compte, on a
vu à quel point notre parc électrique et
notre parc de centrale nucléaire s'est
laissé aller et donc on a joué notre
sécurité électrique et les Français ont
dû payer très cher leur électricité
alors même que leurs parents et leurs
grands-parents ont payé pour ce parc. Et
donc c'est la même chose en alimentaire.
On a travaillé pour avoir aujourd'hui
une alimentation de très haut niveau
parce que nos agriculteurs, ils
bénéficient pas des mêmes molécules que
les autres. Il travaille, on va dire, en
moins 10 anances moléculaire. Aucun
autre pays que le nôtre n'a autant de
transposition législative aussi
difficile. C'est-à-dire que quand une
directive européenne sort de Bruxelles,
et bien elle vient dans les Parlements
nationaux. Et il y a des Parlements
nationaux en Allemagne en particulier où
la directive elle sort, elle est aussi
épaisse ou peu épaisse qu'elle est
rentrée. Chez nous, il y a toujours
inflation. Il y a toujours inflation
avec cette inflation de normes qui amène
les agriculteurs à renoncer.
C'est-à-dire que j'ai parlé des
problèmes de revenu, mais il y a aussi
la dureté du métier. Il y a aussi
l'image qu'ils ont. L'image que certains
bobos qui viennent habiter tout d'un
coup en milieu rura et
ceux qui râent parce qu'il y a un coq.
Voilà, ceux qui râent parce qu'il y a un
coq ou parce qu'il y a du fumier ou ou
de la terre. Effectivement, moi j'en ai
dans ma propre commune à à LondUV, je le
vois bien comment ça se passe. C'est
Néorurau qui considère que finalement
l'espace là-bas est un lieu de
vilégiature, mais seulement pour les
autres, il a toujours été un lieu de
travail. Et donc évidemment, il y a
confrontation et avec des agriculteurs
qui ont de moins en moins d'élus he
quand on regarde aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale, il y a pas 15
députés d'origine agricole et donc on se
trouve dans une situation où les
agriculteurs se sentent très éloignés
finalement du citoyen consommateur et
donc petit à petit il lâche beaucoup
d'exploitations ne sont pas reprises et
c'est tout notre socle agricole qui
vaille et au départ on a une logique
c'est de se dire oh on peut se nourrir
avec les importations des autres sauf
que dans le contexte crise climatique
que l'on connaît parce que quand le
bruit des charsque
voilà quand le bruit des chars se sera
tu parce que on peut être optimiste et
penser qu'à un moment donné le bruit des
chars se calmera on reviendra au
principal problème qui est la crise
climatique. Et au début, nos
importations, elles seront comme
d'habitude dans la fable, pas chè et
puis petit à petit, elles seront de plus
en plus chères dans le contexte
climatique que l'on connaît. Et on va
devoir remettre des milliards et
peut-être qu'on pourra pas si en déton
saura pour relancer un socle agricole
qui est vraiment celui-là. Derrière
l'agroalimentaire et le deuxième socle
parce qu'il y a pas de souveraineté
alimentaire sans socle agricole mais il
n'y a pas de souveraineté alimentaire
sans capacité à transformer les produits
issus de la ferme France. Et ces
produits issus de la ferme France
aujourd'hui et ben il y a ces industries
agroalimentaires qui les transformment.
C'est des tissus très fragile. Les taux
de marge des industries agroalimentaires
sont aujourd'hui faibles. C'est-à-dire
que par rapport au montant de capitaux
fixes qu'il nécessite, ils sont faibles.
Ça peut être contesté par certains
effectivement distributeurs qui estiment
qu'ils ont augmenté. Non, ils sont
revenus dans une logique normale. Mais
ce ce contexte là, cet écosystème là
tient notre sécurité alimentaire et
c'est très important que les
consommateurs, les citoyens
consommateurs en aient conscience.
Anthony, tu as tourné à la ferme ?
Ouais.
Tu as choisi une ferme, on t'a
recommandé une ferme. Quand tu t'es
pointé là-bas, les agriculteurs, ils
étaient contents que tu mettes un peu de
lumière sur leurs conditions.
Ouais. Bah, j'ai choisi une ferme en
Normandie parce que donc dans
l'histoire, c'est une une ferme laitière
et donc ta droite, tuas un breton.
Ouais, je sais. Il y a les choix entre
la Bretagne et la Normandie. Bon, j'ai
choisi la Normandie. Euh, dans le
cinéma, on a des repéreurs. Donc, il y a
une repéreuse qui a repéré des fermes
sur un brief que je lui ai donné. Et
j'ai visité quatre fermes, je dirais. Et
en fait, la première ferme que j'ai
visité, c'est la ferme dans laquelle on
a on a tourné. Et tout de suite, j'ai eu
un coup de cœur déjà parce que les lieux
étaient vraiment représentatifs de ce
que je voulais montrer. Je voulais
montrer quoi ? Je voulais montrer une
ferme qui a une grandeur passée, une
histoire. Et pour ceux qui verront le
film, ils verront que c'est c'est pas
une petite ferme. C'est une ferme où on
sent qu'il s'est passé des choses, qu'il
y a une histoire derrière avec des
grands bâtiments, mais une ferme qui
petit à petit peut-être a aussi perdu un
peu de son sa sa grandeur. Et donc ça
c'était la représentation du lieu qui
était assez pertinente par rapport à mon
histoire et surtout j'ai eu un coup de
cœur en fait avec les les fermiers. Il
s'avère que cette ferme, elle est tenue
par un couple qui a une trentaine
d'années, c'est Mathias et Mathilde.
Mathias a repris la ferme de ses de ses
parents. D'ailleurs, je les salue en
effet, Mathias et Mathilde. Et en fait,
quand j'ai rencontré Mathias, j'ai eu
l'impression de voir le personnage de
mon film. C'est que le personnage de mon
film, c'est un éleveur aussi qui a une
trentaine d'années qui est pas du tout
l'archétype
d'un agriculteur qu'on peut avoir en
tête ou qu'on peut voir même souvent
dans les représentations au cinéma ou à
la télé des agriculteurs. qui essaie de
construire son réseau,
qui essaie de construire son réseau, euh
qui euh qui a pas un physique bourru
mais qui est plutôt frê, qui a des idées
novatrices, qui veut faire du bio, qui
veut faire du local, qui essaie de de en
fait de créer quelque chose, une forme
de solidarité entre éleveurs laitier
pour pouvoir avoir plus de poids aussi
derrière parce que le problème aussi des
des éleveurs et des agriculteurs, c'est
qu'ils sont très isolés finalement. Et
donc quand j'ai rencontré Mathias, je me
suis dit bah c'est super en fait, c'est
le miroir direct de mon personnage. Ils
font eux de l'élevage laitier, donc ils
font du lait qui vont dans des
collecteurs, mais ils font aussi leur
propre fromage Neuf Châel. Euh c'est une
appellation en AOP. Et euh et en fait
quand ils ont lu le scénario, ils m'ont
dit "Mais comment tu as fait pour écrire
ce truc ? C'est c'est tellement juste,
c'est tellement réaliste, c'est
tellement représentatif aussi de ce
qu'on peut vivre ou de ce que les gens
qu'on connaisse peuvent vivre que en
fait ça m'a beaucoup rassuré parce que
moi je suis pas paysan, je viens pas de
ce monde là, je suis plutôt citadin et
donc je me suis aussi fixé une exigence
de beaucoup travailler et de beaucoup me
documenter pour être réaliste aussi dans
le dans dans le traitement du monde
agricole.
Qu'est-ce que tu as appris sur le prix
du lait ?
Bah, j'ai appris
plein de choses. Bah déjà, il y a eu les
fameuses crises laitières. Moi quand
j'ai commencé à écrire, c'était en 2019,
donc ça fait longtemps et euh déjà j'ai
choisi l'Ait parce que c'est un c'est
c'est une filière symbolique en France
et que il y a eu des épisodes de crise
laitière. Moi quand j'ai commencé à
écrire, il y avait des 2009, il y a eu
2015 et en fait je me suis rendu compte
d'un truc assez fou au départ je savais
pas, c'est qu'en fait quand ils vendent
leur lait, ils décident pas de leur
prix. C'est-à-dire que ils font pas de
facture et en fait il y a un collecteur
qui vient et qui prend le lait et c'est
lui qui fixe le prix. C'est un peu comme
si nous on allait à la boulangerie et
qu'on disait au boulanger bah ce matin
la baguette moi je vais te l'acheter à
80 centimes.
Et le boulanger il va il va vous dire
mais moi ça me coûte je dis n'importe
quoi 90 centimes. Nous on lui dit bah
non ce sera 80 centimes. C'est comme ça
et puis il accepte. Donc j'ai j'ai j'ai
je me suis confronté à cette réalité. En
fait il faut savoir que c'est pour ça
que je disais ils sont assez isolés.
Eux, ils sont regroupés euh enfin dans
le film, ils se sont regroupés en
réseau, mais moi, j'ai vu beaucoup aussi
d'agriculteurs isolés qui ont pas les
moyens euh que peuvent avoir euh euh les
industriels, les collecteurs, les
distributeurs parce qu' ils sont pas
éduqués à ça en fait. Eux, leur travail
c'est de travailler dans leurs fermees,
de faire du travail, il travaillent avec
le vivant et ils sont pas formés à
négocier. Ils ont pas les codes de ces
choses-là. ils viennent pas de de la
même éducation et donc en fait il ils
connaissent pas les codes mêmes de la
violence de ces négociations et donc en
fait ils se font avoir en quelque sorte.
Moi c'est comme ça que je l'ai ressenti
des des syndicats agricoles.
J'ai pas j'ai pas voulu rentrer dans la
dans la la question politique. Donc j'ai
pas rencontré des syndicats agricoles.
Tu
as rencontré le leur CQ ? leur,
c'est-à-dire
la la MSA
la
la MSA mutuelle
MSA mutuelle sociale agricol la sécurité
sociale euh non pas du tout non non je
me suis pas du tout non je me suis pas
intéressé à à ça moi j'ai rencontré des
des des éleveurs et j'ai essayé de de
comprendre leur métier de comprendre
leur état d'esprit par rapport à ce
qu'il disait tout à l'heure disait ils
se sentent pas considérés
Olivier c'est ça
Olivier ouais ils se sentent pas
considérés et c'est vrai moi au début
quand j'ai commencé à parler avec des
éleveurs, ils étaient surpris
Ils sont dit "Mais qu'est-ce qu'il veut
lui le Parisien là qui vient, il veut
faire un film sur nous ? Mais qu'est-ce
qu'il va raconter ? Pourquoi il veut
nous parler ?" Et très rapidement, je me
suis rendu compte en fait qu'ils avaient
plein de choses à dire et qu'ils étaient
ravis de pouvoir
expliquer leur vie, leur métier, de se
dire "Tiens, il va y avoir un film qui
va parler de nous." Donc comme moi,
j'entends que aujourd'hui, c'est une
cause qui
fait un peu l'unanimité. J'ai
l'impression que c'est une des rares
causes en France qui fait l'unanimité.
C'est-à-dire que on est pratiquement
tous d'accord pour se dire que c'est
quand même bien de soutenir nos
agriculteurs, que c'est eux qui nous
nourrissent. Euh mais en même temps,
j'ai aussi un une autre sensation, c'est
que finalement ils sont pas vraiment
considérés, ils sont pas vraiment
écoutés, ils sont pas vraiment reconnus.
Il y a des trucs que tu as pas pu mettre
dans ton film, tu t'es autocensuré. Euh
ouais, alors pas côté agricult mais côté
nég en effet, il y a des trucs que j'ai
pas mis parce que j'avais peur qu'on me
taxe de caricature et euh on m'a
raconter des choses qui étaient d'abord
que j'ai mise au scénario des certaines
anecdotes de négociation que j'ai fini
par enlever parce que en discutant avec
mes productrices, on s'est dit si on
laisse ça en fait les gens vont pas y
croire et vont se dire que on a trop
forcé le trax. C'est caricatural. Je
peux vous donner un exemple he il y a
une une scène de négociation dans le
film à un moment où c'est un peu tendu
entre le le l'acheteur et et son
fournisseur,
le fameux Marwan Marie et dont je vous
parlais plus tôt m'avait raconté une
anecdote où en fait à la fin de la
négociation bah l'acheteur de grande
distribution ouvre la fenêtre, prend
l'ordinateur de son fournisseur, le
balance par la fenêtre et il lui dit bah
si tu reviens pas la semaine prochaine
avec un prix plus intéressant, c'est toi
qui passe par la fenêtre.
Donc quand on parle de violence tout à
l'heure, tu dis c'est quoi la violence ?
Bah voilà, c'est
c'est à ce pointl ouah moi ça c'est une
anecdote. Il y a pas des plaines chez
les flics. La police s'intéresse pas à
ce harcèlement psychologique.
Donc c'est la première réaction que j'ai
eu. J'ai dit mais c'est pas possible
le mec qui est victime de ça forcément
derrière il va il va je sais pas il va
porter plainte ou il va se plainre il va
pas se laisser faire. Et là, il m'a dit
"Mais il faut que tu comprennes quelque
chose, c'est qu'en fait il est tellement
dépendant de la personne qui est en face
de lui que il va pas aller s'attaquer à
celui qui le nourrit." C'est-à-dire que
s'il perd ce ce contrat, lui, il est
substituable. Il y en a plein des des
concurrents qui font la même chose que
lui. Donc, il peut perdre son contrat et
à ce moment-là, il a tout perdu.
Il y a il y a une police économique qui
s'appelle la DGCCRF sous l'autorité de
l'autorité de la concurrence qui euh qui
traque euh effectivement. Mais
aujourd'hui, la DG CCCRF a subi aussi
des saigners
dans ses effectifs et elle n'a plus la
puissance qu'elle avait il y a il y a 20
ans. Et c'est bien dommage parce que on
parle là d'un sujet extrêmement sérieux
et je vois bien pour faire de la
formation direct, je vois bien
effectivement euh
ces hommes et ces femmes de la GRF qui
aimeraient en faire plus parce que il y
a matière. Il faut bien comprendre que
en matière d'enquête, l'autorité de la
concurrence est confrontée aux
distributeurs et aux industriels. La
moitié des décisions concerne
effectivement
les industriels et l'autre des
distributeurs. Ce qui est
caractéristique, c'est que bon ben des
industriels qui se mettent en groupe et
puis qui négocient effectivement des
prix. Mais devant quoi ? Et ben devant
la force des distributeurs, beaucoup
d'industriels se réunissent et essayent
d'avoir des conditions générales de
vente un peu identiques. Et souvent ben
au départ d'un cadre
qui dénonce effectivement il y a
perquisition et souvent bah on va
remarquer que là il y a tel cartel du
yaourt, il y a tel cartel de la farine
qui s'est formé et à chaque fois les
industriels disent "Ben oui, mais c'est
parce que le distributeur est tellement
fort qu'on essaie de faire un front
commun sur le prix." Et oui, mais il y a
entente c'est interdit. Effectivement,
la loi l'interdit et ils sont
régulièrement condamnés. En ce qui
concerne les distributeurs, euh c'est la
notion de déséquilibre significatif qui
amène leur condamnation. Un déséquilibre
significatif, c'est le fait pour un
industriel d'accepter des conditions de
vente que dans un cadre ou de remise de
rabet, de restour ou de pénalité
logistique, des conditions qu'il accepte
et dans un cadre normal, il les aurait
pas accepté. Mais la loi a dû renverser
la charge de la preuve. C'est-à-dire que
la BAS Corpous en France et dans tout
pays démocratique amène la justice à
devoir démontrer la culpabilité de
l'individu. Là c'est l'inverse. Quand il
s'agit de la grande distribution, c'est
à eux de démontrer qu'ils sont
innocents. Et donc l'autorité de la
concurrence et ben elle agit et elle
condamne. Effectivement donc on a vu
dernièrement Bercy condamner le groupe
Lecler à 33 millions d'euros. pour ne
pas avoir terminé ces négociations
commerciales à temps l'année dernière
parce que les 8 semaines ont été
dépassées et que quand on attend
c'estàdire qu'on met sous le feu plus
longtemps son son fournisseur mais
derrière la variable c'est toujours
l'humain et donc je pense aussi et je
suis d'accord avec Anthony, c'est que
beaucoup de personnes en grande
distribution souffrent d'une certaine
forme de schizophrénie c'est que d'un
côté ils savent très bien que ils sont
aussi citoyens et que ils sont aussi
consommateurs et que dans le fond on
arrive dans un cercle totalement
vicieux. C'est-à-dire que la quête des
consommateurs pour les prix bas amène
les distributeurs à répondre à cette
quête à travers cette violence
commerciale qui leur permet d'obtenir
des prix bas. Sauf que nos industries
agroalimentaires souffrent et que
finalement les effectifs aussi fondent
et que dans le fond et ben les taux
d'emploi bah deviennent euh moins
importants, il y a moins de salaires
injectés et dans le fond c'est toute une
économie et oui et c'est une économie
qui patine. C'est-à-dire que derrière le
grand problème de notre pays en matière
alimentaire, c'est que d'un côté on a un
dogme libre échangiste européen qui
amène à voir des produits
rentrer dans sur notre territoire, sur
le territoire européen et en France des
produits qu'onutorise pas fait avec des
substances qu'on n'autorise pas nos
agriculteurs à utiliser. C'est-à-dire
qu'il y a pas ce qu'on appelle ces
fameuses clauses miroir et je peux
donner l'exemple de la tomate azura au
Maroc qui est une tomate aujourd'hui.
Quand un consommateur achète une tomate
azur, ben il contribue à vider l'Afrique
de l'Afrique de son eau. Il contribue à
importer des pesticides avec une
signature carbone en prime. Au bout du
compte, ce produit rentre très
facilement et concurrence nos produits
Prince de Bretagne, savéol, nos produits
Rougeline. Et donc il n'y a pas équité.
Il y a pas équité. Pourquoi ? Parce
qu'il y a un déséquilibre social sur les
salaires. Parce qu'à Gadier, on n' pas
les mêmes salaires qu'en France. Et que
au bout du compte, on se retrouve avec
des produits à 99 centimes contre des
produits à 2,50 € ou 3 €. Le match pour
certains consommateurs est vite fait.
Je peux te couper Olier ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Euh qui s'en met plein les fouilles ?
Qui s'en met plein les fouilles ?
C'est-à-dire si je t' si je t'entends,
si je te comprends correctement, d'un
côté, on a nos petits producteurs nos
producteurs qui se font un peu essauré.
Oui,
dans en face on a des molécules qui sont
interdites qui sont quand même
importées. Donc encore une fois, nos
agriculteurs sont essoré et derrière il
y a pas de mesure miroir et infiné c'est
encore nos agriculteurs qui se font
essorer.
Alors tu vas me dire que ces grands
groupes font remonter leurs dividendes
ou leurs résultats dans des fonds de
pension, dans des fonds de retraite. Ça
ça paye peut-être la fond les les
retraites des Américains ou d'autres.
Mais moi français qui paye des impôts,
qui subventionne X ou Y mesure positive
pour mes mes fermiers, mes agriculteur
où l'argent va infiner parce que il y a
forcément tu tu parlais de concentration
de valeur, où elle arrive cette valeur ?
Elle arrive dans des fonds de pension,
elle arrive dans des banques, elle
arrive dans les villas de x ou y
personne ? Où ça va tout ça ?
Al moi je suis pas issu d'un milieu
agricole mais d'un milieu ouvrier et je
me souviens bien de mon grand-père qui
me disait toujours et ben regarde dans
le Fistère et c'est un peu normal les
plus riches sont les industriels. Et
donc il y avait des Jean-Charles à
l'époque il y avait des industriels de
l'agroalimentaire qui étaient les
personnalités qui étaient les plus haut
contribuables des départements et ils
ont été remplacés par les distributeurs.
Ils ont été remplacés par les
distributeurs et ce n'est pas, je veux
dire le nombre d'experts comptables, le
nombre de commissaires au compte que je
peux rencontrer dans mes conférences qui
me nourrissent souvent en me montrant ou
voir en me transmettant des documents me
disant "Monsieur Mel, vous avez
tellement raison" parce que la réalité
c'est que prenons un prenons un magasin
de la de grande distribution.
La question la péréquation de la
distribution c'est le chiffre d'affaires
au mètre carré. Donc le chiffre à faire
en mètre carré dit tout. À partir du
moment où vous avez 10000 m² et que vous
faites 160 170 millions d'euros, si vous
faites bien 15 à 16000 € au mètre carré,
je parle même pas des 25 30 35 millions
en essence à côté. Regardons cela.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Il se passe que
on a un distributeur en particulier qui
nous dit "Moi, mes marges sont de 1 %."
Sauf que quand on regarde bien
l'affaire, il y a toujours dissociation
entre le fond de commerce et les murs.
C'est-à-dire que donc la SCI
propriétaire des murs va faire payer
très cher et va pomper effectivement
beaucoup d'argent à un moment donné. Ça
ça va faire le patrimoine et de l'autre
côté les salaires sont aussi très
importants et donc notamment chez
certains indépendants d'un fameux groupe
bleu. À partir de là effectivement quand
vous avez pris 5 6 7 10 millions d'euros
sur votre SCI, quand vous prenez des
salaires et moi je pose la question y
a-t-il aujourd'hui un adhérent aux
couleurs bleues qui prend moins de
100000 € par mois sur son magasin ? Donc
la question elle est très simple. 100000
€ par mois chargé ça fait bien 200000 x
12 ça fait 2004. Si on prend 6 à 7
millions à 10 et je parle pas des plus
gros magasins. À partir de là, on a
véritablement et on n'est plus sur 1 %
de marge, on a véritablement aujourd'hui
des personnes qui se sont enrichies
euh sous couvert finalement de bah d'une
loi qu'ils ont certes bien abordé mieux
que les autres, mais c'est le rapport de
force que l'on continue de tolérer qui
amène cette situation là. Et donc moi je
considère qu'il n'y a pas de cohérence
économique à laisser ça perdurer. Il
faut absolument changer la donne. Et
changer la donne, c'est compliqué. On a
vu, ça fait 60 ans qu'on fait des lois
contre la grande distribution et ça ne
marche pas. La question c'est pourquoi ?
Bah c'est tout simplement un paradoxe
qu'on appelle nous un paradoxe SCP,
c'est-à-dire que la structure de marché
domine le législatif. Elle est trop
forte. Et donc il faut absolument ouvrir
cette structure de marché. pour
permettre effectivement aux autres de
respirer et notamment aux fournisseurs.
Et ce quoi aujourd'hui moi je crois,
c'est qu'on peut encore changer la
donne. On a vu effectivement alors moi
comment j'ai vu monsieur Macron arriver.
Moi j'avais connu Emmanuel Macron dans
la à la commission Atali donc en 2007
qui préparait la la LME, la loi de
modernisation de l'économie et à ce
moment-là, on sentait qu'il y avait
volonté. Et je rappelle qu'Emmanuel
Macron quand il est arrivé au pouvoir en
2017, il a appelé des états généraux de
l'alimentation. États généraux de
l'alimentation, c'est qu'en France,
quand on utilise le terme état généraux,
c'est qu'on a de l'ambition. Et cette
ambition effectivement euh qu'il
portait, s'est traduite par une
organisation des États généraux
extrêmement précise. Et puis et puis est
arrivé ce fameux discours du 11 octobre
2017 à Ringis. Et là, ma grande
surprise, j'entends le président de la
République dire devant toute la
distribution, tout l'agroalimentaire,
tous les représentants des paysans
français que la solution pour le pays
c'était la montée en gamme. La montée en
gamme. On est en 2017 et je me dis c'est
pas possible qu'il disent ça la montée
en gamme. Pourquoi ? Parce que la montée
en gamme, ça veut dire qu'on va produire
pour 20 % les 20 % les plus riches.
Rappelez tout à l'heure mes des cils,
c'est 80 % des consommateurs qui
regardent le prix mais il y a 20 % qui
le regardent pas, qui ont la chance de
ne pas le regarder. Résultat la montée
en gamme, ça signifie la bio, ça
signifie la belle rouge, les opérations
d'origine contrôlée, donc des produits
très chers.
à la décharge d'Emmanuel Macron, il ne
savait pas qu'on allait avoir une
pandémie mondiale. Il ne savait pas
qu'on aurait la crise qu'on a eu avec la
Première Guerre en Europe depuis
longtemps et tout ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui jusqu'à en Mous aujourd'hui.
Il savait pas, c'est parce qu'il est pas
capable d'anticiper.
Il y a pas anticipé,
il y en a d'autres qui ont anticipé.
Voilà, là il y a pas eu anticipation
mais le président devrait revenir
aujourd'hui devant le monde agricole et
je pensais qu'au dernier salon de
l'agriculture, il l'aurait fait et de
dire je me suis trompé et ce qui est
important aujourd'hui, c'est la
couverture de la demande. C'est-à-dire
que les 30 % les plus pauvres doivent
pouvoir manger en origine France. La
classe moyenne doit pouvoir avoir du
rapport qualité- prix en origine France.
Et ceux qui cherchent des produits
théâtralisés, bio et label rouge doivent
pouvoir avoir ces produits s'ils le
souhaitent aussi. Ça s'appelle la
couverture de l'année demandé. La
responsabilité du plus haut magistrat de
ce pays, c'est d'assurer la couverture
de la demande alimentaire à ses
concitoyens. Or, ce n'est pas ce qui est
fait. Il y a trop d'importations
aujourd'hui qui rentrent, 25 à 30 % de
l'assiette des Français sous importation
parce qu'on ne couvre pas la demande. Et
pourquoi on ne couvre pas la demande ?
Il y a qu'à voir nos linéaires œufs en
ce moment. C'est-à-dire qu'on dirait
effectivement que sont complètement
balcanisés. Il manque 300 poulaillers de
30000 poules dans ce pays de poules au
sol. Et donc les gens aujourd'hui
regardent, ils regardent et ils veulent
des œufs qui soient avec un rapport
qualité- prix correct ou plein air ou
effectivement au sol. Mais il y a pour
s'installer une ce qu'on appelle un
ICPE, c'est tout simplement un document
qu'il faut obtenir dans lequel on
explique que l'on va bien faire les
choses. Et donc c'est pour toutes les
installations classées par rapport à
l'environnement. Et ben dans le fond,
quand le pays a faim d'œuf, il faut
faciliter les choses. Ça veut pas dire
qu'on laisse faire n'importe quoi, mais
c'est que on accompagne les projets et
on dit voilà et on vient devant les
Français pour dire là pendant 3 ans, on
doit avoir ces 300 boulaillers qui
doivent sortir de pas payer à fin d'œuf.
Mais oui,
parce que
c'est la protéine la moins chère en ce
moment
et que c'est comme c'est une protéine
qui est peu chère et ben
signal précurseur.
Voilà, signal précurseur. Et
effectivement, on est dans cette
situation où on voit que l'alimentaire
est en train de remonter dans les
dépenses des ménages. Et donc à l'heure
où les ménages effectivement aujourd'hui
sont en train de quitter tout ce qui est
équipement de la maison, tout ce qui est
équipement de la personne et on voit les
difficulté du textile à côté et ben
c'est la responsabilité du premier
magistrat de ce pays que de poser
effectivement les conditions d'une
couverture de la demande quel que soit
le niveau de revenu des Français.
Avant de donner la parole à Anthony,
moi je vais dire Mercosur et œufre
ukrainien.
Oui.
C'est quoi le mercur ? C'est quoi l'of
ukrainien ? Est-ce que le mercur c'est
un effet de manche
qui va encore plus appouvrir nos
agriculteurs
in
sous des prétextes de faire baisser les
prix ?
Incontestablement. Oui. Parce que si on
doit comprendre le mercur, il faut
penser de à quoi on parle. En gros, moi
on m'a dit, et des journalistes me
disent des fois, "Monsieur Mvel, mais
c'est 99000 tonnes seulement de viande
bovine." Et ils me disent "Euh,
finalement, c'est pas beaucoup, mais
comme Jordine, vous mes connaissez
l'équation physique de la bête, ce qui
va rentrer les alloyaux, c'est-à-dire la
partie noble de la bête." Et donc, quand
on repense à ce que sont les alloyaux
sur une bête, c'est 15 % de la bête.
C'est donc finalement non pas 1,2 % de
la production européenne qui va être qui
va rentrer, mais c'est bien plus que ça.
Et et ces alloyaux venus effectivement
des pays du mercur vont venir
concurrencer les appels d'offre publique
en Europe. Et donc cette viande de
mauvaise qualité parce qu'on peut pas
dire ça autrement parce que là
l' goûté
alors je l'ai goûté deux fois et en fait
ce qui est étonnant c'est de penser que
dans le fond cette viande là elle est
vendue pas cher mais on la voit pas et
heureusement qu'on la voit pas parce
qu'elle est pas belle à voir. Elle est
pas belle à voir parce que c'est la
viande de fidelot, c'est-à-dire elle a
été faite avec des hormones de
croissance dans le cadre, on va dire,
d'élevage concentrationnaires. Et donc
ces élevages concentrationnaires avec un
des animaux à l'hctare, nous faut bien
penser en France que quand on me dit des
fois que l'élevage est intensif en
France, quand je vois qu' on est à deux
animaux et demi, trois animaux par
hectare, là ça rien à voir. On est sur
des 400 animaux à l'hectare, 500
parfois. C'est-à-dire que les animaux
n'ont rien et on voit bien, il y a pas
un brin d'herbe, il y a rien. Donc ils
sont nourris effectivement
là directement avec du produit aussi
industriel he bien souvent industriel ou
autre. Et à partir de là derrière
évidemment quand on est
concentrationnaire en volaille, quand on
est concentrationnaire en bovin,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? les animaux
tombent malades et il faut les traiter
avec des antibiotiques et il faut les
faire grossir. Et au bout du compte
aujourd'hui, ben le Mercosour c'est
99000 tonnes de bauvin. Mais c'est la
même chose avec les 200000 tonnes de de
volaille. Euh une volaille c'est quatre
pièces. Il y a deux filets deux cuisses.
Il y a le soliless.
Voilà le soliless. Mais celui-là
derrière bon il est plus compliqué à
faire venir comme ça. Par contre on va
voir les filets de voilaille et 200000
tonnes de volaill en filet. Là aussi, ça
va déséquilibrer les choses. Et qui va
manger ça ? Tous ceux qui consomment des
plats près de par évidemment
euh je dirais le consommateur qui va son
c'est son artisan bouché ou même en
grande distribution qui va manger ça. Ce
sera dans le ce qu'on appelle nous le
food service, c'est-à-dire ce sera dans
les plats préparés du parbier ou des
choses pas cher produit pas cher du
produit premier prix évidemment. Et donc
c'est bien dommage parce que sont encore
les plus faibles qui vont payer la note.
Pour du côté politicien, je te donne la
parole tout de suite après Antonine. Du
côté politicien c'est c'est vachement
bien. On va donner au gu
ça pitance.
Allez
souscouvert accord des prix bas parce
qu'évidemment notre robe libre
échangiste parce que le mercur
j'ai un j'ai un grand paysan que je
connais que je connais beaucoup qui
s'appelle Jean-Pierre. C'est l'ancien
président de la FNB, Jean-Pierre
Fleurri. Jean-Pierre me dit souvent
finalement euh voilà regarde regarde ce
que fait la marchande de bagnole
allemande parce que la vérité
parler d'ursula
voilà c'est que la vérité c'est que
madame Bantenne depuis 2019 où elle est
aux affaires euh elle
avant avant elle faisait quoi
alors avant
elle était ministre de la défense non
elle s'est fait virer non
ouah elle a travaillé dans différents
gouvernements allemands mais il y a une
chose qui est certaine c'est que
certaines pardon c'est que dans le fond
depuis 2019, elle a organisé
un Green Deal. Un Green Deal dans lequel
ça c'est quoi ?
Alors c'est un accord vert parce que la
Commission européenne se veut verte mais
évidemment les premiers à payer la note,
ce sont nos agriculteurs. Et donc en
voulant faire payer la note à nos
agriculteurs, et ben elle a désigné tout
un système qu'on a appelé farm to fork,
c'est-à-dire de la ferme à la
fourchette. Le seul problème, c'est que
madame Balérienne ne s'intéresse pas
beaucoup à l'alimentaire parce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui que c'est la fourchette
qui commande et que donc c'est la
fourchette qui mange ce qu'elle souhaite
manger et que donc
ce qu'elle peut manger.
Ce qu'elle peut manger. Et l'erreur
historique de madame Vandellerérienne et
de ceux qui comme elle font commerce de
la crédulité finalement des citoyens à
traduire leurs envies politiques en fait
de marché, c'est de considérer qu'un
jour on peut décréter un marché bio à 25
%. Imaginons 25 % de la de la surface
agricole utile en bio. La bio
aujourd'hui ne pèse que 6 7000 % euh de
partestomac dans l'alimentaire. Et donc,
on a été montré à des centaines de
milliers d'agriculteurs européens un
marché qui n'existait que dans la tête
de cette majorité européenne qui voulait
l'avoir. On ne décrète pas un marché
sauf à vouloir amener des centaines de
milliers d'agriculteurs dans un sens
interdit. Et quand je vois les
conversions aujourd'hui de certains qui
reviennent vers le conventionnel parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres choix, on peut
se poser effectivement la question de
cette Commission européenne qui depuis
2019 poursuit toujours un but mais qui
va être dans le fond de d'être libre
hors sol
et très libre échangiste. C'est-à-dire
que c'est un libre échangisme échevelé
comme si le terme protectionniste était
devenu un gros mot. Mais je suis désolé,
il y a il y avait un un vieil économiste
du 19e siècle qui disait toujours le
protectionnisme n'est pas un gros mot,
mais quand vous protégez, vous
investissez deux fois plus pour pouvoir
lever les barrières protectionnistes.
Mais protéger quand on veut élever et
ben c'est quelque chose de naturel. Or,
c'est plus le cas en Europe et il est
temps que ça le redevienne derrière.
Effectivement, quand vous laissez les
distributeurs, mais pas que les
acheteurs de la grande distribution, les
acheteurs de la restauration foyer aussi
quand vous laissez effectivement
cantine aussi
bien sûr les dogmes du prix bas, ça fait
beaucoup pour le socle agricole et le
socle alimentaire, le libre échange, des
produits de partout qui rentrent à
moindre prix, à moindre coût avec
finalement derrière et ben euh une
socialisation qui est moins forte et on
sait très bien que le SMIC en France à
1460 €. C'est pas la même histoire que
ce qu'on peut trouver aujourd'hui au
Maroc ou ailleurs, mais même en Espagne
et même au Portugal où il est à 600 € je
crois. Donc on n pas les mêmes
conditions sociales mais on a voulu
faire cet espace uni et cet espace uni
marche très bien dans les services parce
que les produits sont pas comparables.
Mais moi 1 kil de de port breton quand
il part à l'export, il est très
comparable au kilos de port allemand. Et
donc cette Europe aboutit à jeter des
bassins de production les uns contre les
autres avec effectivement nos
agriculteurs qui vivent avec des coûts
sociaux français et des normes qui leur
sont imposées très dures surtransposées.
On peut pas s'étonner qu'effectivement
ça n'aille pas.
Attends Anthony, je je le travaille
encore 2 minutes parce que je le sens
bien chaud. Je te redonne la parole tout
de suite après.
Olivier, là on est dans un contexte de
guerre euh guerre énergétique donc
guerre calorifique donc infiné guerre
dans les assiettes. On a le D3 d'Ormous
pour les engrais. Ça commence à être un
petit peu constipé de ce côté-là. On est
fâché avec Popov 1er en Russie. Vladimir
il est un peu fâché. Il produit aussi
beaucoup d'engrais.
On va avoir des perturbations de chaînes
logistiques pour nos cultures, donc pour
aussi notre alimentation.
Comment toi tu sens les choses en terme
d'anticipation du gouvernement sur ces
perturbations qui vont se traduire
infiné dans les assiettes ? Tu les sens
parce qu'il y a une scène dans le film
où ils vont voir un ministre.
Tu les sens réfléchis,
tu les sens stable sur leurs appuis ou
tu les vois signer le mercur rapidos
parce qu'ils savent qu'on va avoir des
perturbations du prix alimentaire et
qu'ils sont prêts à sacrifier nos
agriculteurs parce qu'ils ont la
solution plan B du mercour qui va
arriver même avec un coût énergétique de
transport plus cher
ça sera toujours moins cher que chez
nous. Est-ce qu'ils utilisent les
agriculteurs d'autres pays pour
artificiellement maintenir la population
? C'est dat avec des prix bas
en partie ? Oui. Mais ce qui est très
inquiétant c'est que
le mer le mercour est une chose mais
hormous en est une autre. On appelle ça
nous un choc exogène, c'est-à-dire que
c'est un choc qui n'était pas prévu.
C'est le signe noir. Et ce signe noir,
il arrive là euh à un moment donné où
euh on est dans un état de tension pas
possible. parce que je rappelle quand
même que nous avons aujourd'hui une
dette qui est importante et donc c'est à
3300 milliards. On est dans une
situation où on a aussi à côté de c'est
un taux d'endettement important mais on
a aussi un taux de prélèvement
obligatoire qui est très important. On
est champion d'Europe avec 56 %
prélèvement obligatoire. C'est-à-dire
que il faut bien penser qu'aujourd'hui
euh on évolue dans un état prévaricateur
vis-à-vis de la valeur ajouté. Et c'est
ça qui est dangereux, c'est-à-dire que
là, il y a un choc énergétique qui va
jeter effectivement un surplu
d'inflation. Comme je l'ai dit, ce
surplus d'inflation va il immédiatement
mettre à terre un certain nombre
d'entreprises. Je pense notamment à nos
amis restaurateurs parce que déjà
aujourd'hui, on va dire que dans ce
pays, je pense aux 430000 restaurants et
je pense déjà, il y a pas grand monde
qui mange assis en ce moment en France.
Il va y avoir encore moins parce que les
Français sont en train de s'arrêter là
de consommer parce que la situation est
quand on sera au 5 semaines, on aura les
premiers résultats et donc dans ces
résultats, on va sans doute voir que ça
y est, l'inflation est repartie et il
est du devoir effectivement de ceux qui
nous gouvernent de gérer notre sécurité
alimentaire et là d'anticiper avec tout
de suite des plans de filière parce
qu'on sait pas ce qui peut se passer.
C'est-à-dire que euh ouvrir Hormous,
Hormous reste fermé. De toute façon,
c'est le plus grand choc énergétique que
l'on est connu depuis la guerre du
Kipour et 73 qui est en train d'arriver.
Et donc c'est je vous rappelle qu'en
2008, on les l'inflation, les étiquettes
n'avaient décollé que de 2,8 % en 2008.
On a vu que là en 2022 c'était 25 sur
l'alimentaire.
Ormous reste bloqué.
Alors quelque part ça va être 25 à 30
points et là on ne passera pas on ne
passera pas sur ces prixlà. Et donc je
rappelle aussi que les restos du cœur
c'est 180 millions de repas mais 50 %
des repas sont servis à des gens qui ont
moins de 35 ans dans ce pays. Et donc il
y a une sécurité alimentaire et il
convient que le président de la
République ne s'en défausse pas, qu'il
considère qu'aujourd'hui ses plans
alimentaires doivent être imaginés parce
qu'on ne sait pas ce qui se peut se
passer aujourd'hui du point de vue
inflationniste. Anthony, ton prochain
film, ça va être sur quoi ? Ça va être
sur les émeutes de la fin en France ?
Non, je pense pas mais ce sera forcément
sur un sujet qui aura un retentissement
social, sociétal. Enfin, moi je
considère qu'un cinéaste,
il doit faire deux choses. Il doit
s'emparer d'un sujet qui raconte le
monde et il doit le faire à travers des
destins humains et intimes. Donc c'est
ce que j'ai essayé de faire dans mon
film. Ça raconte c'est tout ce monde de
l'alimentaire, comment les prix sont
fixés, nous quand on va au supermarché,
comment ces produits sont arrivés dans
nos rayons, à quel prix ils ont été
fixés. Donc il nous informe sur cette
réalité mais aussi c'est des destins
humains. Il y a un sujet dans mon film
en fait, moi je me suis rendu compte
aussi au montage par exemple que il y
avait un sujet important,
c'est le sujet de l'entrisme,
c'est-à-dire de se dire est-ce que on
peut rentrer dans un système comme ça,
puissant et avec des bonnes intentions,
des convictions essayer de le de le
changer, de le modifier parce qu'il y a
toute une jeune génération aujourd'hui
qui viennent sur le marché du travail
avec des convictions, des idées et de se
dire qu'ils vont un peu bousculer les
les choses. Et souvent moi ce que je
vois en tout cas c'est que quand on
rentre dans ces systèmes là bah on
narrive pas à les faire bouger. Et ce
qui se passe c'est même l'inverse.
C'est-à-dire que c'est le système qui
vient vous transformer. Et c'est un peu
ce que raconte mon film avec ce ce
personnage d'Audre qui est le personnage
principal qui essaie de rentrer dans ce
système de le faire bouger. Bon je vais
pas tout spoiler mais on va vite se
rendre compte que ça va être compliqué.
C'est très bien tourné. La musique est
super bonne. Je peux citer le
compositeur ? Bah
tu crois que tu es venu pour pousser un
cady ou quoi ? Bah
attends, bah je vais pousser quand même
le cady parce que tu parles de la
musique, il s'appelle Benjamin Grossman
et c'est Ouais, c'est je trouve que
c'est un travail formidable qu'il a
fait.
Combien ce film t'a coûté ?
Moi personnellement,
non, je suis sûr que ça t'a coûté de
l'argent.
Ça m'a coûté 7 ans de ma vie déjà. Donc
c'est beaucoup. Euh non, il a coûté en
terme de budget, il a coûté aux
alentours de 2800000 €.
Les subventions,
je sais pas ce que tu appelles des
subvention mais euh
parce que mes impôts t'ont servis à
éduquer les gens grâce à tout.
Ah bah sans doute un petit peu mais de
façon indirecte. C'est-à-dire que
je suis content.
Ouais mais de façon indirecte.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a quand même bon on
en parle souvent, c'est c'est un sujet,
je sais pas si tu as entendu parler tout
ça, du CNC, de la façon dont il financ
le cinéma, d'où vient cet argent, est-ce
que c'est de l'argent public ou pas. Il
faudrait qu'on leur parle de nos droits
d'auteur qu'ils ont soldé. Continue.
Bon et donc le CNC il est financé par
majoritairement par des taxes mais des
taxes qui sont prélevées sur les tickets
de cinéma. Donc c'est en fait toi quand
tu vas au cinéma bah tu finances
potentiellement les autres films. Donc
tu mon film donc je sais pas si tu es
allé au cinéma récemment mais peut-être
que tu as financé mon prochain film.
La dernière fois que j'ai été au cinéma
c'est parce que j'ai été invité par un
réalisateur.
Ouais
et euh
et voilà.
OK.
Il s'appelle il s'appelle Albert.
Ah bah oui, je vois de qui tu parles
alors.
Et et on était très content d'aller au
cinéma avec Albert.
OK. Et ben je t'inviterai à mon prochain
film comme ça.
Tu peux inviter Albert d'ailleurs.
Ouais. Et ben avec plaisir. J'adore son
travail. Je sais qu'il est venu ici et
j'ai vais regarder
qui regarde les interviews et qui va
voir celle-là qui va envoyer un SMS.
Et ben Albert, voilà si tu veux venir
voir mon film, c'est avec grand plaisir
et je serai ravi d'en discuter à suite
avec lui.
Conseil Albert, c'est un bon film. Euh
je reviens sur notre expert,
le contexte de guerre économique euh tu
dois suivre un petit peu l'impact
logistique que l'énergie a sur tout un
tas de filières contrairement à notre
gouvernement qui est censé prévoir parce
que gouverner c'est prévoir
et ne pas prévoir c'est gémir.
Et oui et là on les entend s'agiter
avant de gémir. Je sais pas si tu as vu,
ils bougent beaucoup les bras, ils font
du bruit avec leur bouche.
Il commence à gémir là. Tu as remarqué à
l'Union européenne là ? Et oui, il
s'inquiète.
Il il s'inquiète. Il s'inquiète plus
pour eux ou ils s'inquiètent pour le
pays.
Alors, je sais pas pour qui s'inquiète
mais j'espère qu'il s'inquiète pour les
concitoyens européens. peux lâcher le
truc fort et expliquer à ma communauté
qu' fin quand il y a ce genre de
perturbation
que tu nous décris et que je décris un
choc pétrolier pire que 1973 un choc
pétrolier sous stéroïde parce que la
mondialisation la la concentration
énergétique des produits est beaucoup
plus importante qu'en 1973 et que le
réseau local est beaucoup plus faible
qu'à l'époque explique avec des mots
crus sans politesse ce que ça donne.
Quand il y a un trou d'air sur
l'alimentaire,
ben on peut regarder en Afrique.
C'est-à-dire que quand on regarde en
Afrique, vous regardez au Nigéria, 40 %
du revenu disponible
est consacré à l'alimentaire.
En France, j'entends certains ministres
me dire "Mais c'est 12 13 % mais c'est
faux parce que c'est considéré qu'on est
tous les mêmes revenus et tous les mêmes
goûts alimentaires." En réalité
aujourd'hui, quand on fait partie en
dessous du 5e descil, donc en dessous de
la médiane carrément quasiment, 50 % des
personnes sont plutôt entre 15 et 25 %.
Et donc ça veut dire que euh je prends
notamment sur des gens qui sont seuil de
pauvreté. Le seuil de pauvreté, c'est on
va dire là le revenu médian auquel on
soustrait 60 %. Donc on arrive à peu
près à 960 970 €. Et au seuil de
pauvreté, imaginez un peu, on raisonne
par unité de consommation. On va se
retrouver avec des augmentations de 20
30 %. Mais on l'avait déjà vu en 2022.
Moi, je je suis à Morlet euh je dirais
là où j'ai mon poste euh des familles
monoparentales euh qui euh derrière
quand elles ont payé leur loyers
notamment avec deux enfants, euh se
retrouvent avec un budget d'environ 400
€ par mois. 25 % de 400 € ce sont des
gens qui n'ont pas d'épargne. Il y a pas
d'épargne de précaution. Donc vous
augmentez allez 2022, en mai 2022, il y
avait déjà 3 4 5 % d'augmentation 10 %
en novembre 2022 10 % de 400 ça fait 40
tous les mois quelque part derrière les
40 tous les mois qui se chaînent et donc
au bout de 12 mois c'était déjà 480 €
qu'il n'avaient pas et ils ont dû
descendre en gamme c'est-à-dire mettre
en jeu une descente en gamme sur la
qualité nutritionnelle des produits à
renoncer à des produits pour d'autres et
évidemment il y a là une forme
d'injustice et quand il
un choc psy psychologique énorme
bien sûr parce que on participe beaucoup
de la qualité des produits que l'on
mange. Intellectuellement, c'est très
satisfaisant de manger des produits
qu'on estime et je vois trop aujourd'hui
de personnes en France de concitoyens
qui effectivement vivent à une
moindisence alimentaire et là ça va
s'amplifier parce que le choc que l'on
que l'on vit là c'est au mois de
novembre au mois de novembre octobre
novembre décembre ça va être terrible
parce que quelque part déjà on voit que
dans un registre normal on est sur 17 18
milliards par mois dépensés pour
l'alimentaire. Là, on est sur une
quinzaine de milliards tous les mois.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, les Français
utilisent l'alimentation comme une
variable d'ajustement. Ça va être encore
pire là. C'est-à-dire que si Hormous
n'est pas débloqué, si on reste dans cet
état, alors effectivement le choc sur
les plus fragiles va être terrible. et
dire que je disais à un ministre des
finances de monsieur Macron qui écrit
des bouquins euh je dirais un peu
simpflement.
Ouais. Voilà. Je lui disais
c'est notre idole ici.
Un chèque alimentaire serait très
important. Un chèque alimentaire basé
sur l'origine France. Un chèque
alimentaire pour les plus jeunes, pour
les étudiants, pour tous ceux qui sont
en popérisation. Très important. Jamais
voulu entendre parler de cela
mais ça va revenir sur le tapis. Ouais,
bien entendu. Je vais me faire l'avocat
du diable.
Tu imagines un choc alimentaire dans la
5e puissance mondiale ?
Oui, mais on sera pas seul à subir ce
choc alimentaire. C'est le Royaume-Uni
aussi les autres vont le vont le subir.
Tout le monde va le va le subir.
C'estàdire qu'en fait
l'Union européenne peut laisser faire ça
parce que si tu fais un un chèque
alimentaire euh pour acheter de
l'origine France, c'est de la subvention
déguisée. Et oui, surtout qu'on on s'est
aperçu d'une chose, c'est que
l'inflation quand elle part, elle touche
l'alimentation tout de suite, mais le
second tour, il est sur les service
parce que derrière effectivement les
salaires ont augmenté partout et parce
que les entreprises ont dû faire face à
la demande des salariés relativement à
l'inflation. Et donc, on s'est aperçu
effectivement que les salaires ont
augmenté mais quand même relativement
moins que l'inflation. Donc on a une
situation critique qui se joue
socialement avec une certaine mauvaise
humeur et quand on regarde nos
démocratie aujourd'hui européenne, ce
qui est on va dire à craindre et moi
j'ai une vision purement économique de
l'Assemblée nationale, c'est-à-dire que
dans le fond de nos 3/3, moi je vois les
choses différemment, c'est-à-dire que
économiquement on a un tiers de France
heureuse. Il y a incontestablement à 30
% un/ers de France heureuse. Il y a
un/ers de France laborieuse qui se lève
le matin et qui comprend pas pourquoi
elle ne gagne pas plus. Effectivement,
elle va subir là de plein fouet ce dont
on parle là. Et effectivement, c'est
très important. Je parle souvent du
vouloir d'achat et le vouloir d'achat
est un élément d'instabilité quand il se
creuse par rapport au pouvoir d'achat.
Et donc à côté de ce tiers de France
heureuse, ce tiers de France labouruse,
on voit apparaître un tiers de France
sédicieuse parce que c'est ils ont
l'impression qu'ils n'y arriveront plus
économiquement. Et quand je demande à
ces jeunes supporters à Bress partout
que dans mes communes de vie, je ces
jeunes me disent ben on n plus
l'impression qu'on va y arriver. Alors
ce qui est assez curieux c'est que quand
on prend le tiers de France laborieuse,
on a 50 % qui part chez LFI, 50 % RN. Et
quand on prend le tiers de France
séduieuse, on a 50 % qui partent chez
les filles, 50 %. C'est-à-dire que j'ai
des collègues américains qui me disent
"Mais dans le fond Olivier, tu vois,
vous êtes en train de devenir comme
nous. vous allez faire vos élections sur
l'économie et l'économie est en train de
prendre là le pas parce que ce que l'on
va connaître si ce choc énergétique
parce que là quand on voit le prix du
gaz ce soir on se pose la question de
comment on va la jouer l'hiver prochain
et donc on ne pourra pas faire comme des
magiciens. Donc je ne sais pas si il va
y avoir une coalition pour libérer
Ormous et la façon dont ça va se passer.
Mais si ça ne se passe pas dans les 3 qu
prochaines semaines, alors l'économie se
sera déjà fait inoculer les germes
inflationnistes qui emporteront ce qu'on
dit là.
Anthony, toi dans le milieu de du
cinéma,
est-ce que tes potes réalisateurs
discutent de ce qu'on discute avec
Olivier ? Non, je vais être franc avec
toi. Non, on n'est pas dans des
discussions aussi poussées. Mais en tout
cas, moi mes potes réalisateurs, oui,
bien sûr, ils s'arget de société mais là
c'est des discours d'experts. Nous, on
n'est pas des experts. Il faut savoir
quel est notre rôle.
Je te rassure, on n'est pas des experts
non plus. Du
bah lui, c'est un expert quand même je
trouve moi. Mais après toi, je sais pas.
Pas du tout.
Mais donc nous à notre niveau en tant
que cinéaste, bien sûr, on est curieux
du monde qui nous entoure et on essaie
de s'emparer de ces sujets-là. Donc bien
sûr qu'on parle de sujets qui seront
importants. Alors moi c'est des sujets
économiques parce que j'ai un passé
là-dedans que j'ai fait des études
économiques. C'est des sujets qui
m'intéresse. Mais il y a aussi
l'éducation populaire à travers l'image.
Tu crois encore ?
Bah bien sûr. Enfin et au-delà de
l'image à travers l'histoire en fait les
histoires, le pouvoir des histoires.
Donc ça peut être du cinéma mais ça peut
être aussi des bouquins, ça peut être
n'importe quoi. Moi je considère que je
me suis éduqué grâce au cinéma. C'est
pour ça que aujourd'hui je fais du
cinéma. C'est-à-dire que j'ai appris
plein de choses. Moi les les je pense
que les émotions intimes, par exemple,
on les apprend au cinéma puisque le la
définition d'une émotion intime, c'est
qu'elle est intime, donc elle est pas
montré. Donc on va pas on va pas
t'éduquer à l'intimité. Donc comment tu
fais pour t'éduquer à l'intimité ? Bah,
il faut que tu ailles chercher ça dans
des histoires, dans des livres, dans des
films pour voir des personnages
confrontés l'intimité qui vont partager
ça avec toi et du coup ça va t'éduquer.
Moi, j'ai appris euh je pense mais comme
beaucoup de monde, je pense à draguer
cuisine avec Maité
par exemple et j'ai appris à draguer en
allant voir des comédies romantiques, tu
vois. Alors, peut-être que c'est pas les
meilleurs exemples, mais en tout cas, je
Oui, moi je crois beaucoup au pouvoir
donc déjà d'instruction émotionnelle,
intime, mais aussi et c'est pour ça que
je fais des films qui traitent de sujets
de société, euh souvent on me reproche
par exemple, on pourrait me dire que mon
film est un film dossier
en disant "Ouais, c'est pas complètement
du cinéma." Bah si, moi je trouve que
c'est pas un sous-genre de faire un film
dossier et c'est pas qu'un film dossier
d'ailleurs, c'est aussi un thriller. Il
y a toute une il y a il y a il y a il y
a toute une réflexion aussi sur la
cinématographie, sur la mise en scène,
sur toutes ces choses-là. Mais en fait,
moi je prends ça comme un compliment
quand on me dit euh il a traité un sujet
de façon très réaliste, on est à la
limite du documentaire. Bah ouais,
j'avais une exigence, j'ai poussé mon
sujet, j'ai travaillé pendant 5 ans sur
le scénario et en fait, j'en suis fier
qu'on puisse me dire après bah ça colle
vraiment à la réalité des choses et tu
soulèves des lièvres qui étaient
important d'être soulevé. Et en plus de
ça, euh j'en fais un un une œuf de
cinéma parce que il y a aussi un travail
sur la lumière, sur les décors, sur euh
les plans, sur la mise en scène et aussi
euh il y a ces fameux parcours
émotionnels de personnages qui peuvent
aussi t'apprendre des choses sur bah
comment nous on se positionne en tant
qu'être humain face à un système comme
ça. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Quoi ? Est-ce
que
J'ai trouvé que tu présentais le requin
tueur d'une façon très sensible.
Bah oui, je crois aussi en fait. Je
crois, en tout cas, c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de faire. J'ai essayé de ne pas
juger mes personnages. Euh si on prend
tous les personnages du film, même les
plus méchants, donc le entre guillemets
le requin tueur, il montre aussi à des
moments euh qu'il est humain et
physiques, tu les sors d'où ?
Les siens.
Ouais.
Alors, tu parles du fait qu'il soit
toujours debout, par exemple. Euh bah le
fait qu'il soit toujours debout euh
c'est une c'est de la mise en scène
quoi. C'est-à-dire que tu te dis à un
moment euh comment ça peut s'incarner
euh ce ce truc d'un personnage,
on a discuté avec ton acolyte en terme
de négociation euh de pression.
Non, ça on en a pas parlé de ça, tu
vois. Ça c'est un truc qui est venu
ensuite au scénario. Après, j'avais
aussi des gens qui m'ont aidé au
scénario de bon des ce qu'on appelle des
consultations dans le dans le dans le
milieu du cinéma. Et puis j'avais un un
co-auteur à la fin qui m'a aidé aussi à
travailler sur les sur les dialogues et
qui m'a aussi aidé sur cette histoire de
miss et en fait cette histoire de
toujours debout, on l'a trouvé ensemble
en ping-pong en se disant bah comment on
peut faire pour avoir quelque chose en
fait de visuel parce que c'est ça qui
est important dans le cinéma qui va nous
permettre de faire passer des choses sur
le personnage. Donc là, il est toujours
debout et je vais pas révéler la suite
mais bon voilà, il y a des moment voilà,
on révèle pas la suite mais en tout cas
il y a il y a toute une séquence où en
effet ce personnage ce qui est assez
fort je trouve c'est que ce personnage
on dit rien sur lui. Il est très
mystérieux dans le film. On connaît pas
son pas trop d'éléments de son passé. Il
parle pas beaucoup, il se livre pas
beaucoup mais par
entre les lignes, tu peux
entre les lignes en fait il y a plein de
choses qui se passent.
C'est dès l'écriture, on travaille sur
ça mais on travaille aussi bien sûr avec
l'acteur
des croissants congelés.
C'était parce c'était pour faire passer
qu'il était aussi passé par le poste de
la petite.
Ouais. C'est aussi pour dire que lui
s'il fait finalement c'est pas un bling
bling quoi. C'est-à-dire que il fait pas
ça après pour rouler en Porsche et aller
se mettre dans dans dans des villas.
Non, en fait il c'est un personnage qui
vient en fait aussi d'un milieu modeste
qui a eu une un désir de revanche
sociale, un désir d'ascension sociale
mais c'est plus un truc intérieur. S'il
a un mantra ce gars-là, c'est en fait il
faut bouffer les autres avant qu'il vous
bouffent. C'est bien, on parle de
d'alimentaire, mais moi je me suis dit
que ce personnage le le quand il se lève
le matin, il se dit euh si je bouffe pas
les autres avant qu'il me bouffe, je
suis mort parce que il vient d'un milieu
où certainement il a vu sa famille aussi
se faire bouffer et donc il s'en est
fait des des des des croyances, des
choses comme ça. Et il y a beaucoup euh
de choses qui régissent aujourd'hui
notre monde qui sont basées sur sur ces
idéesl et et donc il fait pas ça
forcément que pour flamber. Il fait ça,
fait son boulot habité par ça et il peut
très bien aller dans un appart hôtel et
bouffer des croissants surgelés. Donc
voilà,
l'universitaire qui est à côté de toi,
arrêtez les gars avec les questions là,
le l'université qui est l'universitaire
qui est à côté de toi, je lui pose une
question. Est-ce que le milieu
universitaire a besoin du milieu du
cinéma
pourrait s'aimer un peu plus autre
autrement que dans le tout petit panel
des de d'étudiants que tu peux avoir à
l'année ? Est-ce que quand tu as été
contacté par un réalisateur, tu t'es dit
enfin
on va essayer de dessimer un peu plus
large population.
En fait, un enseignant chercheur quand
il arrive à un certain âge, ce qui ce
qui est mon cas, euh on a
des minag
Oui, on a on a beaucoup écrit on a
beaucoup écrit. Alors, ce qu'on nous
demande de faire une thèse de doctorat
puis après de soutenir encore une autre
thèse qu'on appelle l'habitation digne
des recherches qui vous permet de
d'avoir vos propres doctorants. Et donc
pour garder de l'intérêt effectivement
au métier et ben on s'aperçoit que la
vulgarisation est très intéressante et
vulgariser et vulgariser ses
connaissances ça fait partie du du job.
Et moi, je considère que à mon échelle,
j'ai essayé de vulgariser mes
connaissances auprès de d'Anthony et
qu'Anthony les a particulièrement bien
rendu. C'estàd je suis très fier de du
travail qui est fait et quand je
considère aujourd'hui les trois plus
grands films de management en France, et
ben je considère que la guerre des prix
n'a pas à rougir.
Et les deux premiers c'est quoi ? Et ben
en fin de compte, c'est le cultissime
ressources humaines qui est un film je
dire très important qui a marqué
effectivement son époque avec la notion
de plafond de verre hein qui était euh
on va dire qui a été présenté à ce
moment-là. C'est-à-dire que un film
pouvait montrer aussi qu'on pouvait
traiter de la théorie effectivement et
puis en même temps de la pratique. Et
c'est un film que je considère qui est
très actuel mais aujourd'hui tout
manager doit regarder ressources
humaines. Et puis après dans les années
20056 il y a eu un film euh qui m'a
donné envie d'aider Anthony.
99 francs.
Non
violence des échanges en milieu tempéré.
violence des échanges en milieu
tempérique qui a qui a lancé Jérémy Rier
euh et qui est vraiment un film sur le
consulting incroyable. Euh il faut voir
violence des échanges en milieu tempéré
parce que il y a le requin consultant
seior, il y a tout. Et moi, je conseille
toujours euh mes étudiants de voir de
voir ces films. Et maintenant, il y a la
guerre des prix. et la guerre des prix
euh comme violence des échanges en
milieu tempéré, il y a ce côté thriller
économique qui est important parce que
effectivement euh les négociations
commerciales dans les chaînes de valeur,
c'est comme des thrillers et que vous
négociez aujourd'hui du blé à
destination de l'Algérie, que vous
négociez aujourd'hui de la volaille, je
dirais pour des enseignes de grande
distribution, il y a un côté thriller
dans les équipes aujourd'hui et avec le
contexte géostratégique que l'on
connaît, ce sera encore plus vrai. Et
donc si le cinéma peut aider nos
étudiants à comprendre comment ça se
passe que c'est vrai que même si
aujourd'hui il y a plus de contrat
d'apprentissage parce que moi je j'ai un
master qui est en contrat effectivement
d'alternance et nos étudiants sont
alternants maintenant master 1 master 2
bah il n'empêche que voir ces situations
les comprendre et ben je trouve que là
ça honore le le cinéma et je trouve
qu'il y a pas assez de films économiques
sur l'entreprise
aujourd'hui mais qui qui qui qui soit
sous le couvert d'un angle et et d'une
présentation qui soit tenue par son
metteur en scène. Et ça c'est ce qu' a
bien fait Anthony.
Et Anthony te jette des fleurs là.
Bah ouais.
Est-ce que tu veux tu veux aborder,
compléter, partager ?
Je veux je veux Ouais, je pense aussi
que mon parcours m'a permis de pouvoir
faire ce film parce que il y a des films
qui auraient été fait. Alors, les deux
références qu'il a cité, moi c'est des
références aussi que j'avais en tête
sans sans qu'on en parle hein. Euh mais
c'est vrai que il y a aussi eu d'autres
films peut-être parfois un petit peu
plus caricaturaux sur le monde de
l'entreprise et qui le reflétait pas de
manière assez réaliste selon moi. Et je
pense qu'on peut pas facilement en fait
s'emparer de ces sujets-là quand on les
a pas non plus vécu. En fait, souvent
les gens me disent après les projections
"Comment tu as fait pour avoir des
dialogues ?" Enfin, il vous voit donc
comment vous avez fait pour avoir des
dialogues aussi réaliste ? Parce que
moi, je travaille dans ce monde-là. Et
en fait, moi je l'ai vécu de l'intérieur
parce que j'y ai travaillé. C'est des
c'est des langages, c'est des codes,
c'est même des façons de marcher, c'est
des façons de s'habiller, c'est des
façons de se comporter. Et dans le
cinéma, ça ça passe beaucoup par
l'image, par la façon dont les acteurs
vont pouvoir incarner le rôle. Et donc
je pense que j'ai réussi à faire passer
ça, ce qui fait que après un spécialiste
dise "Ça sent le réel et c'est les
meilleurs compliments que je puisse que
je puisse avoir." Ouais.
Je vais vous poser des questions
d'Internet.
Première question. Euh pourquoi les
agriculteurs ne créent-ils pas une forme
de coopérative qui distribuerait leur
nourriture vers les marchés en ville en
imposant leurs prix ?
C'est ça ça existe un peu. Euh
alors c'est une bonne idée. Alors les
les agriculteurs se sont formés en
coopérative depuis longtemps déjà. Mais
euh aujourd'hui euh ce qui se passe,
c'est que il y a des problèmes qui sont
des problèmes liés à l'émergence de
nouveaux marchés. Donc le local en
éteint et aujourd'hui on a des
agriculteurs qui sont atomisés et on a
beaucoup de mal à mutualiser les
productions pour les faire venir au cœur
des villes. Donc il y a des agriculteurs
qui sont plus business que d'autres
parce qu'aujourd'hui la réalité c'est
que s'il y a bien une notion qui est en
train de s'imposer en agriculture, c'est
bien celle de chef d'entreprise. Et donc
beaucoup d'agriculteurs
qui ben constatent que les prix ne
viennent pas sont en train de
s'organiser en organisation de
producteur en coopérative nouvelles ou
d'utiliser leur coopérative aussi parce
qu'il y a des coopératives qui sont en
train de s'y mettre aussi parce que
c'est très important que de pouvoir déjà
être champion du monde de ses
productions dans sa région d'origine. Ça
s'appelle le local et donc le local
aujourd'hui bah il n'est pas
complètement couvert. Et donc je
comprends l'appel de cet auditeur à ce
que les agriculteurs puissent y aller
parce qu'il y a toujours ce dilemme et
ce dogme entre le local et l'export.
Moi, j'ex je veux dire je ne pose pas
les deux, c'est-à-dire qu'on a besoin de
de des deux, mais par contre, on doit
bien couvrir les deux. C'est-à-dire que
quand on fait du local, il faut
absolument pouvoir avoir des circuits
logistiques et plateformiser finalement
euh l'offre et la demande parce que le
c'est la plateforme qui va permettre là
d'avoir euh la demande et l'offre, les
inscriptions des agriculteurs qui
permettront au consommateur de se dire
"Bon ben, je vais pas aller au marché là
et ne pas trouver mes œufs." Mais je
suis certain de les trouver parce que la
plateforme me dit que tel agriculteur
sera bien là. Et là, on en est encore
très loin. Donc, je crois beaucoup
aujourd'hui euh au fait que les
nouvelles technologies vont amener
finalement à fluidifier la relation. Et
quant à l'export, l'agriculture
française a appris que elle ne devait
plus considérer l'export comme une
variable d'ajustement à son marché
domestique. Il faut produire
spécifiquement pour l'export dans les
conditions et les attentes attendues par
les pays.
J'ai une question plus personnelle.
Si tu devais donner un conseil à un
distributeur, un grand distributeur, tu
dirais de proposer
un panier spécial alimentation de guerre
fait localement avec moins de calories
exogènes qui puisse contenter les
estomacs avec de la qualité locale mais
sur des produits basiques.
Ben, je conseillerais deux choses. Le
premier, c'est de ne plus vendre un
produit sans indiquer quelle est la part
qui revient aux agriculteurs sur ce
produit. Première chose,
tu crois au père Noël toi tu m'as dit
Oui, mais je pense que on va y venir
parce que et peut-être que l'épisode
qu'on va vivre va nous amener à cela
beaucoup plus vite qu'on le croit.
C'est-à-dire que
ça fait peur ça.
Mais oui, ça fait peur parce que euh
je je sais très bien par exemple, j'ai
j'ai des enfants et j'ai des garçons qui
ont 24 et 27 ans.
Prêt à porter un fusil. Et
il y en a un qui est d'ailleurs dans les
forces spéciales et qui est commando de
marine.
Il est il est marsouin,
il est à l'Orient. Et donc à partir de
là, je sais aussi leur appétence pour la
viande rouge. Mais je sais très bien
parce qu'ils me le disent aussi, papa
aujourd'hui nous chez nous, on n'a plus
les moyens d'acheter de la viande rouge
comme on achetait avant. Pourquoi ?
parce qu'elle a augmenté de plus 35 %
depuis 2022 et qu'aujourd'hui évidemment
et ben la question c'est que qui
aujourd'hui accueille ses amis avec du
filet de bœuf qui invite quatre
personnes et va les achet un filet de
bœuf d' 1,8 à 40 € le kilo, c'est-à-dire
quasiment 80 € de viande rouge là sur la
table qui plus grand monde. Et donc
évidemment les gens sont descendus en
gamme sur quoi ? Sur le port et la
volaille. Voilà pourquoi la volaille est
en train de se substituer au bœuf et la
et la volaille est sur une voie royale
parce qu'elle est moins chère. Mais il
nous manque aussi des élevages de
volailles parce qu'on est dans une
situation où aujourd'hui et ben on a des
autoroutes de l'importation qui se
créent parce que la consommation de
volaille augmente plus vite que notre
capacité à installer des élevages. D'où
le fait de mon appel à la couverture de
la demande. Donc je suis très inquiet
parce qu'effectivement
on risque d'avoir la rentrée d'une
nourriture et d'aliments de faible
qualité nutritionnelle et sanitaire
origine Mercosour Thaïlande ou ailleurs.
Et puis de l'autre côté et ben des
personnes qui vont devoir faire des
choix, c'est-à-dire en fin de compte
manger moins. Et quand on voit le nombre
de personnes qui aujourd'hui sautent un
repas, pas par plaisir, pas forcément
pour les régimes à la mode, pour le
jeune intermittent, non, là c'est ça
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le choix. Et
souvent on regarde bien aujourd'hui et
ça donne bien l'esprit. Quand vous
prenez les 10 déciles de consommation et
vous regardez le petit-déjeuner,
chez 30 % des gens, il n'y a plus de jus
d'orange le matin. À partir du 4e et 5e,
6e descil, vous avez un une marque de
distributeur. 7e, 8e, vous avez
effectivement une marque comme Tropicana
ou autre. Et puis dans au 9e et 10e des
ci, c'est les 20 % les plus aisés. Là,
vous avez euh en fait des jus détoxes,
des jus différents qui sont faits en
presse agrume le matin par les
personnes. C'est dire si la consommation
est différente. Mais donc on voit tout
de suite les conséquences. C'est moi je
pense aux 50 % les plus pauvres qui sont
en train de vivre un vrai déclassement
alimentaire. Et le déclassement
alimentaire auquel on va assister va
être, on va dire, catastrophique. Et je
sais que certains distributeurs
partagent mes idées parce que j'en parle
avec eux. C'est-à-dire la situation
aujourd'hui qui les amène à se dire à un
moment donné comment on peut faire.
C'est-à-dire que prenez 30 % des plus
pauvres, mais ils ne vont plus en grande
distribution aujourd'hui. Ils vont sur
les marchés communautaires, ils vont sur
des marchés aujourd'hui qui sont du
déstockage alimentaire. Et c'est ça,
c'est les 30 % les plus les plus
fragiles. Les 20 % les plus riches, eux,
ils vont chez Grand frais, ils vont
différents. Pourquoi ? parce que ils ont
des revenus qui sont assez inéllastiques
à la crise. Donc ne reste plus en grande
distribution que 50 % est la classe
moyenne et donc c'est elle qui va le
plus souffrir de la situation que l'on
vit aujourd'hui et surtout ceux qui ont
des enfants. Après, on s'étonnera aussi
que les la génération Z et les millénes
ne font pas d'enfant mais effectivement
c'est un sacrifice aujourd'hui
financier. les jeunes me le disent que
d'avoir un enfant et dans la situation
et le contexte de de guerre que l'on
connaît, c'est pas l'envie de faire des
enfant qui va prendre les aides et les
milléniols. Effectivement, donc là aussi
c'est une c'est un on va dire derrière
une externalité négative comme on dit
nous en économie de la situation. Donc
je suis très inquiet effectivement de la
situation aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
de la précarité alimentaire de certains.
Autre question internet. Quand on gagne
moins de 1200 € par mois, est-ce qu'on
doit culpabiliser d'acheter à manger
dans les magasins discount, même si on
pense aux agriculteurs pour
interrogation ?
Ça ça c'est une question qu'on pose
souvent en en fin de projection,
c'est-à-dire quel doit être le rôle du
consommateur ? Le consommateur est
responsable. Et la première chose que je
dis moi, c'est ça, c'est surtout il ne
faut pas culpabiliser le consommateur
parce que le consommateur, il fait comme
il peut déjà là cette personne qui
touche moins de 1200 € par mois, bah si
elle peut pas faire mieux, elle peut pas
faire mieux. Et surtout en fait, j'ai
l'impression qu'on est en train de
remettre sur le dos du consommateur tous
les problèmes et que ce serait à nous
consommateur de tout régler. Mais je
trouve que c'est un peu facile. Et
souvent les consommateurs en fait, ils
sont pas informés. S'ils avaient le
niveau d'information qui leur permettait
de faire les bons choix, de savoir que
quand ils achètent tel produit, en fait,
ça peut poser un problème en fin de
chaîne, bah peut-être qu'il ferait
différemment. En fait, quand quelqu'un
qui a 1200 € rentre dans un supermarché,
pour moi, il devrait pas avoir cette
question de se dire euh est-ce que là le
produit que j'achète, il va bien
rémunérer celui qui a produit la matière
première agricole. En fait, ça devrait
être normal. On devrait se dire moi
quand je rentre dans un supermarché, je
sais que les produits qui sont proposés,
ils respectent les droits de chacun. euh
ils ont rémunéré justement tous les
maillons de la chaîne. Et donc euh ce
serait à nous consommateurs de faire ce
boulot, de se renseigner, de savoir si
les euh produits qu'on nous met en rayon
respecte bien. Moi, je pense que c'est
quand même ça peut-être le rôle du
distributeur qui met en rayon ses
produits et qui doit peut-être s'assurer
que les produits euh sont respectueux
d'un certain nombre de maillons.
Mais prenons prenons par exemple la
situation, le printemps va arriver le
printemps va arriver avec les conditions
climatiques de l'hiver qu'on a eu
extrêmement pluvieux. Euh moi dans toute
la ceinture légumière bretonne depuis
Paint Paul jusqu'au conquet, les gars ne
rentraient pas dans les champs. Et donc
on va voir là aussi et je m'attendais à
des produits du maréchage très cher, à
des légumes très chers euh au printemps,
c'était sans compter, sans effectivement
les tensions géopolitiques. Et donc je
me dis mais non d'un chien, qu'est-ce
qui va se passer ? Quand on voit déjà
aujourd'hui et quand on réfléchit, ça
apparaît absolument incroyable. On prend
une salade, une salade aujourd'hui sur
Paris.
Ben, on ira 1,70 1,80 la salade presque
2 €. On est plus chass salade. S'il y a
160 180 g de matière sèche, c'est le
bout du monde. Ça fait 10 € du kilo. 10
€ du kilo. Et donc quand on regarde
derrière et quand on verra le prix des
tomates parce que si les
agriculteursemandent
du prix c'est bien parce que le coût
effectivement des engrais mais le coût
de l'énergie a beaucoup augmenté et on
va se retrouver dans une situation où la
péréquation devra bien se faire sur les
prix à un moment donné ou alors on aura
moins. Mais aujourd'hui les
distributeurs sont en train de
s'inquiéter. C'est pas tellement des
prix qui leur sont proposés c'est
d'avoir ou pas de la camé à ce point-là.
Mais bien sûr. C'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui la situation sur les œufs
et ben quelque part elle peut vite venir
parce qu'à partir du moment où les
agriculteurs euh constatent parce que
derrière il faut faire le plein des
tracteurs, faut faire le plein partout,
fiou tout tout ça et
bien sûr et donc l'énergie,
l'électricité et donc évidemment ils
vont demander des hausses les donc sur
la volaille, des hausses sur le porc,
des hausses sur le bovin, mais des hauss
sur les légumes. Et donc évidemment,
c'est cette fameuse inflation qui va
être inoculée et déjà elle aurait été
assez importante de par les conditions
climatiques que l'on rencontre. Mais là
je dirais ça va être le cas. Et on on ne
différencie même plus le sol et le
horors sol parce que le sol les légumes
par exemple et le hors sol le port. Mais
le port, elle lui des contraintes
d'énergie aussi particulières. Et donc
en fait, il va y avoir effectivement des
demandes de hausse des agriculteurs à
leur coopérative partout qui vont être
importantes et tout le monde va le
payer.
Tony, tu veux rebondir un petit coup ou
je peux poser une autre question ?
Non, vas-y, vas-y. Ouais, vas-y.
Je la découvre en même temps que vous.
Euh, peut-on offrir 2200 calories par
jour à chacun avec une production
uniquement nationale ? Point
d'interrogation,
régime alimentaire type année 50, 60,
70.
Il faut bien se rendre compte de ce
qu'est la ferme France parce que des
fois moi je je suis issu d'un d'une
région où on parle d'agriculture et de
pêche. Et souvent je dis la pêche mais
la pêche c'est 1 milliard d'euros. La
pêche franche c'est 1 milliard d'euros
12000 pêcheurs. L'agriculture France la
ferme France c'est 80 milliards. 100
milliards quand les prix sont un peu
plus élevés. Mais l'agroalimentaire
derrière, on est sur plus euh de 400
milliards. Et donc, on a effectivement
aujourd'hui une situation où on doit
produire pour permettre à tout le monde
de manger et notamment à ceux qui
veulent manger en origine français. Et
c'est là que je reviens sur la
couverture de la demande. C'est-à-dire
que si quelque part monsieur Macron
s'était intéressé à l'agriculture
totalement depuis 2017, il aurait
appliqué le principe de couverture de la
demande pour que tout le monde puisse
avoir 2200 calories en origine France,
quel que soit son des revenus disponible
par unité de consommation. C'est ça
aimer son pays. C'est ça prendre soin de
son pays. Et je sais pas en 2027 qui il
ou elle sera élu, mais je lui demande
d'avoir ce qu et ce soin de sa
population du point de vue de
l'alimentaire. couvrir la demande,
obligé et dire à son ministre de
l'agriculture, il faut que tu couvres la
demande. C'est-à-dire que je ne veux
plus cette saisure insupportable que je
vois monsieur, je vous promets une
chose, c'est que si jamais un jour je
gagne plus, je viendrai sur l'origine
France. Non, la ferme France aujourd'hui
est capable de nourrir tout le monde et
les agriculteurs sont capables de
nourrir tout le monde à condition qu'on
les laisse nourrir la France.
C'est-à-dire que dans le fond, chaque
fois qu'il y a une demande
d'installation d'un jeune agriculteur,
euh ce ne soit pas des recours en série
parce que effectivement le bourgeois qui
s'est mis en tête de venir acheter telle
propriété ne supporte pas alors du sang
du coq à autre chose. Et donc on a
vraiment un besoin de concorde sociale
autour de l'agriculture et il faut que
finalement nos concitoyens comprennent
que là par les temps qui sont en train
d'arriver
avoir du CER et du soin de l'agriculture
c'est nous sécuriser et prendre soin de
nous tous.
C'est peut-être aussi faire des
économies auprès de la sécurité sociale
parce que on est aussi ce qu'on mange.
Question internet. Pense-t-il qu'on
qu'on reviendra à l'époque où il faudra
avoir son propre potager élevage pour se
nourrir ?
Ce serait intéressant et c'est déjà
intéressant pour ceux qui le font.
Est-ce que l'État va taxer les tomates
sur le balcon ?
Mais même nous aujourd'hui, comment on
sait qu'un pays comment c'est qu'un pays
va bien du point de vue de son
alimentation ? Il y a deux agrégats pour
ça, c'estd de calcul économique. Ce
qu'on appelle le taux d'autosuffisance
alimentaire, on le calcule filière par
filière et en France, il est en train de
s'effriter. Et le deuxième, c'est le
taux de dépendance aux importations. Et
ce taux de dépendance aux importations
est en train de monter et et en
particulier dans la filière avicole et
dans la volaille parce que c'est le
poulet qui est très demandé. Donc
derrière effectivement chacun de nous
peut se poser la question de son taux
d'autosuffisance alimentaire et ce sont
taux de dépendance aux achats au GMS ou
sur les marchés. Et c'est quelque chose
qui sera qui sera intéressant. Moi je
sais qu'un de mes un vraiment un ami
cher qui était un éleveur de porc que
que j'ai perdu qui était un chic type
qui s'appelait Joe Moile et qui est mort
d'un cancer du poumon. Jo me disait
toujours, "Tu verras, un jour il faudra
protéger nos élevages."
Et dans le fond euh attention parce
qu'il y a un livre qui s'appelle La
guerre du pétrole qui se passe au
Royaume-Uni et qui est particulièrement
prospectiviste sur ce qui doit se passer
parce que je vous rappelle que on a
choisi dans le modèle alimentaire
d'avoir des chaînes de valeur qui sont
extrêmement courtes d'un point de vue
temporel. Aujourd'hui, un un magasin est
vidéos, il y a plus de stock derrière.
Tout est en surface commerciale et les
stocks aujourd'hui sont roulants, ils
sont dans les camions. Et donc il faut
absolument penser à ça. Et donc
aujourd'hui, j'espère que ceux qui nous
gouvernent et notamment les trois
ministres qui ont en charge finalement
un peu notre sécurité alimentaire,
Bercily, l'agriculture, la santé, notre
premier ministre, notre président
s'occupe de de de ce point-là en se
disant effectivement que c'est très
important de penser que un choc
énergétique, oui, mais un choc
alimentaire ça pourrait arriver aussi.
Tu crois au Père Noël,
tu sais comment l'Union européenne fait
pour avoir sur papier des stocks
alimentaires ?
Sur papier ?
Ouais. Il congèle des plaquettes de
beurre.
Alors ça ça a été un moment donné
effectivement où dans le cadre de la
Pâque, on participait de la sorte.
Aujourd'hui, c'est plus le cas. Et
aujourd'hui, on est dans une situation
où c'est le plus offrant, qu'il y a du
beurre et on l'a vu parce que s' un
produit qui a augmenté depuis 2022,
c'est bien le beurre
200 %. Non.
Ouais. C'est-à-dire qu'en fin de compte,
le beurre a terriblement augmenté. Il
joue en yoyo. Mais tout simplement
pourquoi ? Parce qu'avec 1 L de lait, on
a un pourcentage de matière grasse et un
pourcentage de protéines. Mais on peut
pas changer cette donne là. Donc si tout
si on décide avec ces matières grasses
de faire autre chose, du fromage pour
les je dirais burgers ou autre chose de
la Mozza, on peut pas faire du beurre et
visser vers ça. Et donc les choix qui
ont été faits ont amené effectivement
des restrictions sur le beurre et donc
aujourd'hui ben le beurre est était à ce
prix-là. Ce qui en fait un produit de
semiluxe aujourd'hui quand on voit le
prix de la plaquette de beurre de de 250
g, la fameuse 2000 livre de beurre de ma
grand-mère.
Je pose quand même la question mais tu
as déjà répondu. Est-ce que la g la
généralisation de l'affichage du prix de
revient agricole sur les étiquettes va
ou peut réellement modifier le rapport
de force dans les négociations entre les
centrales d'achat et le producteur ?
Tout ce qui responsabilise le
distributeur est important. C'est-à-dire
que je je mets pas tous les
distributeurs dans le même sac.
aujourd'hui, il faut bien distinguer les
distributeurs qui sont loyaux loyaux et
qui essayent de faire des efforts. Et
donc on peut pas dire aujourd'hui alors
c'était le cas de Lidl mais c'est moins
le cas depuis le départ de Michel Birot.
Euh c'est pas le cas d'Aldi, c'est pas
le cas de d'Auchamp, c'est pas le cas de
Carrefour, c'est pas le cas de Lecler.
Mais il y a deux enseignes qu'il faut
quand même euh féliciter parce qu'elles
essayent de bien faire les choses
et Intermarché qui toutes les deux qui
toutes les deux essayent de passer euh
dans une logique où effectivement ils
intègrent et ils privilégient dans le
référencement des produits en origine
France. Et ce faisant, même si dans le
fond il reste dur hein parce que les
informations qui me parviennent les
négociations, c'est que les équipes de
Thierry Cotiè chez Intermarché
continuent à être dur mais ils sont plus
loyaux du point de vue de l'origine
France et de façon à permettre je pense
à tout un chacun et notamment en plus
fragile de dispositif. Il y a déjà des
démarches qui existent, je sais pas si
vous connaissez c'est qui le patron par
exemple, mais sur les briques de lait,
on a le détail de du revenu agricole de
la part qui revient ensuite au
transformateur ou ou au distributeur.
Donc ça existe ces produitsl et on se
rend compte d'ailleurs alors après c'est
des produits qui sont peu chers ou donc
je pense que la question de l'élasticité
est plutôt positive pour le consommateur
mais ils sont les consommateurs sont
prêts à mettre quelques sentiments plus
sur des produits comme ça et ça et ça
marche plutôt bien
des produits pas chers.
Des produits pas chers. Ouais. Ce qu'on
appelle nous des bienji fen,
c'est-à-dire des des prix dont on des
produits dont peut augmenter le prix
sans qu'il s'en vendent moins.
On les connaît parce qu'ils sont abonnés
à notre compte Twitter.
Ah ben voilà.
Euh question qui n'est pas l'internet
qui est de du monsieur à ma droite
Anthony. Tiens bah je te laisse la lire
tiens. Tu vois tu tu fais ton timide.
Ça y est, tu m'as fait perdre la ligne.
Pardon. Anthony, qu'est-ce que tu
attends de ton film pour interrogation ?
parce qu'il t'appartient plus
maintenant. Tu veux faire des passages
en école, en forum, tu veux te présenter
à la présidence,
pourquoi pas ? Il chercher un homme tout
à l'heure ? Non, pas du tout. Je vais
pas du tout me présenter à la
présidence. Non, déjà, j'aimerais que
mon film permette de montrer une réalité
qui est invisible pour le grand public
déjà parce que tout ce dont on a parlé
sur les fameuses négociations, ça c'est
un truc réservé aux initiés. Les
initiés, ils savent comment ça se passe
mais le grand public ne sait pas. et je
m'en rends compte en montrant le film où
les gens hallucinent en me disant "Mais
c'est pas possible, ça se passe pas
comme ça." Donc déjà ça vertu pour moi
déjà euh une vertu pédagogique
informative pour que les gens puissent
savoir euh comment euh ces produits
arrivent dans les rayons et comment euh
les négociations se font. Après la
deuxième chose, moi que j'espère aussi,
c'est que ça provoque des prises de
conscience et que peut-être que les gens
derrière vont se dire tiens euh je vais
peut-être réfléchir à deux fois la
prochaine fois que je vais aller faire
mes courses, déjà où je vais aller faire
mes courses
pour la propre robustesse du pays.
Oui, mais parce que là, on dit euh on n
pas parlé d'autres alternatives, mais il
y a moyen aussi d'aller acheter ses ses
produits et son alimentation ailleurs
que dans les supermarchés. Je n'appelle
pas au boycott des supermarchés.
Moi-même, je vais encore au supermarché.
Mais par exemple, depuis que j'ai fait
mon film, moi je me suis inscrit dans
une AMAP. Donc voilà. Et je me suis
rendu compte de quoi ? Je me suis rendu
compte que les légumes que je récupère
tous les mercredis soirs, ils sont moins
chers. Ils sont
ils sont meilleurs.
Et donc
ça marche aussi pour le chapon de Noël.
Bah certainement. Ouais. Et donc après
voilà, il y a la map mais il y a
d'autres il y a d'autres choses.
Maintenant, il y a plein d'endroits en
France aussi où on peut faire
de on peut aller dans des circuits de
cours de vente directe directement à la
ferme dans des magasins spécialisés.
Donc et après on peut aussi aller au
supermarché et au supermarché on peut
aussi faire attention. Il y a aussi des
des endroits où euh au-delà des
centrales d'achat euh il y a aussi euh
des magasins qui vont chercher leurs
propres fournisseurs de leur côté et qui
nous des partenariats avec des euh
producteurs locaux et qui ont dans leur
rayon alors c'est des petits endroits
mais c'est déjà bien si on achète ces
produitsl.
Question : est-ce que le cinéma, la
fiction a un rôle à jouer sur des sujets
de société ? être en quelque sorte
lanceur d'alerte.
Oui. Alors,
je pense au film Dark Waters.
Ouais, bien sûr. Ouais.
Sur l'épace.
Ouais.
Par exemple.
Oui. Oui. Donc moi, je le pense bien
sûr, sinon je ferai pas du cinéma. Moi,
je me considère pas comme comme un
lanceur d'alerte parce que dans Dark
Waters, on parle d'une histoire réelle,
les noms sont cités, ainsi de suite.
Moi, dans mon film, c'est de la fiction.
Je je pointe pas du doigt
une enseigne en particulier. Donc, je
suis pas en train de lancer une alerte.
Mais mais à ta question, est-ce qu'on
peut changer le monde avec le cinéma par
exemple ? Moi je crois que oui bien sûr.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'en fait la seule
chose qui fait changer les gens c'est
quoi ? C'est pour moi c'est l'émotion.
C'est aussi la bouffe dans le frigo.
Oui mais en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que qu'est-ce qui fait que tu vas
acheter plus une bouffe qu'une autre et
que tu vas aller la mettre dans ton
frigo ? Qu'est-ce qui peut faire changer
tes comportements dans la vie ? Pour
moi, c'est l'émotion. Le rationnel, il
sert à comprendre le monde, à se dire
"OK, voilà comment les choses
fonctionnent." Mais il y a plein de
choses qu'on comprend et on se dit "Bah
ok, il faut que je change mes façons de
faire mais on les change pas."
Je peux te casser tes rêves ?
Vas-y, casse mes rêves.
Et il y a il y a une phrase dans ton
film qui résume bien tout.
Oui. Qui qui est quoi ?
À la fin c'est toujours une question
d'argent.
Ben d'accord. Mais l'argent c'est quoi ?
C'est de l'émotion. Bien sûr. Et tu
crois que l'argent, ça sert à quoi ?
L'argent ça sert à t'acheter des choses,
à gonfler ton ego, avoir un statut
social. Donc ça procure des émotions.
Pour moi, dans la vie, tout est qu'une
histoire d'émotion en fait. Et donc si
tu arrives par la fiction ou par le
cinéma à toucher les gens au niveau
émotionnel, tu vas beaucoup plus les
impacter que si tu leur fais un article
de journal et qu'il comprennent quelque
chose de façon très rationnelle. Enfin,
moi c'est mon point de vue, hein. Euh
donc euh c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi
le cinéma parce que je pense qu'en effet
quand tu fais bouger quelqu'un sur le
plan émotionnel, bah peut-être qu'après
il va bouger dans ses actes. Et euh de
ce que je vois dans quand je projette
mon film et quand je vois la réaction
des gens, il y a des gens qui sont venus
me voir à la fin du film, qui se sont
effondrés en larme des agriculteurs et
qui m'ont pris dans leurs bras comme ça
et qui m'ont dit "Mais merci, c'est ce
que mon père a vécu. S'il y a des gens
qui peuvent comprendre avec votre film
comment ça se passe, peut-être changer
leur leur façon de faire, ce serait
incroyable." J'ai une autre anecdote
aussi. J'ai quelqu'un que j'ai rencontré
au salon de l'agriculture qui travaille
pour un label. Donc il essaie de faire
en sorte de labelliser des industriels
qui respectent justement toute la chaîne
de valeur et ainsi.
S'appelle Arnaud Mondbourg.
Non, il s'appelle pas Arnbourg. Non,
il s'appelle Ludovic Brindjunk. Et et
donc il m'a dit "C'est incroyable parce
que moi j'ai vu ton film et je me suis
dit en 1hure et3 tu as réussi à faire et
peut-être même à faire mieux. que moi ce
que je fais depuis 10 ans en travaillant
sur mon label parce que avec 1h et demi
de ton film, les gens vont comprendre
comment ça se passe, ça va les toucher
et peut-être ça va leur donner envie de
bouger. Donc
tu sais que entre toi et nous
Ouais. on prend deux trois gars, on fera
plus en 10ant en 6 mois que que disant
on fait les autres.
Venez, on y va. Ouais.
Tu as fini ta réponse ?
J'ai fini ma réponse.
Je peux t'en poser une une autre
question ? Bien sûr.
Euh dans le film, tu mets en lumière
l'entre soi politicien, le jeu de
pouvoir,
c'est quoi ? Point interrogation des
gens du même milieu qui jouent au poker.
Point interrogation.
Ouais, en tout cas au-delà même du monde
politique, hein, je il y a une séquence
où je parle du fait que que ce soit les
industriels, que ce soi les gens de la
grande distribution, que ce soit les
politiques, que ce soit les
journalistes, ce sont des gens qui euh
sont issus des généralement des mêmes
statuts sociaux. euh qui ont fait les
mêmes études. Euh donc en fait ils se
connaissent tous et ils jouent un peu à
se faire la guerre les industries, les
grandes enseignes. Mais bon après ils
vont boire des pots ensemble et et ils
rigolent et plus il y a affinité
d'ailleurs. Ils vont aussi passer leurs
vacances ensemble et ainsi de suite. Et
puis les politiques c'est pareil, ils se
connaissent et les journalistes c'est
pareil. Donc en fait il y a un espèce
bien sûr d'entre soi et les
agriculteurs, c'est un peu ce que je
disais tout à l'heure, ils sont en
dehors de de ce monde là, de ces codes
là. Il
ils sont dans le vrai monde en fin de
compte. Ils sont dans dans le monde
concret. Bah, ils ont les pieds dans la
boue quoi.
Et les mains dans le terroir. Question :
Le film est sorti il y a une semaine
déjà.
Ouais. 5 jours même. 5 jours. Faut être
précis parce que tu sais en ce terme de
cinéma le jour un jour près ça compte.
Et sur Sinkerview, ça compte beaucoup
d'être précis d'ailleurs. Donc je répète
la question. Le film est sorti il y a 5
jours.
Tu as des retours de politique de
coopérative pour interrogation. Est-ce
que le film a pour but d'être un support
au débat dans des écoles ou autres ?
Ouais. Donc il y a des projections qui
s'organisent déjà aujourd'hui par
exemple, je sais qu'il y a un un prof en
prépa économique qui a amené toute sa
classe pour aller voir le film et pour
ensuite en faire un débat et en
discuter. Moi, je vais aussi animer des
projections débat avec des lycéens. Il y
a le Sénat qui va projeter notre film.
Il y a une en ce moment, il y a une, je
crois que tu en parlais tout à l'heure,
il y a une commission d'enquête sur les
marges de la grande distribution et donc
le film va être projeté au Sénat. Il
devait être projeté là à la fin du mois,
mais bon, ça a été retardé mais il sera
projeté. J'ai rencontré la semaine,
tu connais le sénateur qui est
agriculteur ?
Non, dis-moi,
je te le présenterai, il est sympa. OK,
continue.
Et euh la semaine oui, la semaine
dernière, j'ai aussi fait une projection
débat où il y a un assistant
parlementaire qui est venu me voir et
qui m'a dit "Il faut que votre film
passe à l'Assemblée. Donc, on est en
contact avec eux pour projeter le film à
l'Assemblée." Donc voilà, ça c'est très
bien. Ça veut dire que les politiques
s'en s'en peuvent peut-être s'en
emparer, mais je me fais pas non plus
d'illusion. Je je reste très complet.
Euh
le politique est opportuniste aussi,
hein.
Absolument. Et puis bon, je je sais pas
où ça mant mais en tout cas moi je suis
ravi de le montrer à ces gens et j'irai
défendre mon point de vue de cinéaste.
Euh après, il y a quand même un truc moi
qui m'embête, c'est que j'ai beaucoup de
réactions des politiques, j'ai des
réactions des agriculteurs, j'ai des
comme tu dis des des lycéens, des gens
comme ça. Donc il y a plein de gens qui
commencent à s'emparer de film et
bizarrement il y a un maillon dans cette
chaîne qui est le distributeur qui qui
réagit pas beaucoup, qui parle pas
beaucoup de mon film et moi ça
m'intéresserait qu'ils aillent voir ce
film. Ça m'intéresserait qu'on puisse
aussi organiser un débat euh avec ces
gens-là euh mais un débat sain où on
peut discuter tranquillement et essayer
de se dire les choses avec tous les euh
tous les participants de ces fameuses
négociations et moi je trouverais ça euh
super. Donc peut-être que je crois au
Père Noël aussi mais euh j'aimerais bien
ouais qu' qu'il voit c'est à la mère
Noël aussi là
peut-être mais moi voilà moi j'ai envie
qu'il voit ce film et je vais me battre
pour que ce soit le cas et pour qu'ils
en parlent.
C'est un sujet tabou pour le
distributeur et je pense que avoir
l'absence de réaction parce que il y a
deux films en même temps qui sont qui
sont sortis. Il y a le le rural hein de
Bergeon qui est qui est sorti euh et
puis la guerre des prix. Euh deux films
sont totalement différents. L'un est un
peu un pané gérique sur effectivement un
homme et la guerre des prix c'est tout
autre chose. Et donc je comprends bien
aussi pourquoi les distributeurs aiment
aller verser une larme surale. Mais sur
le sujet le plus sérieux qui est le
sujet de la guerre des prix, moi je
pense que les distributeurs ont
blacklisté le film. Ils l'ont blacklisté
parce qu'en
c'est la suputation ça Olivier. C'est
ça, c'est ma supputation mais je suis
puput un peu là.
Ouais. Mais je suis assez je suis assez
suivi et on me parle assez parce que je
forme aussi beaucoup. J'ai formé ça fait
25 ans que je je forme soit des
acheteurs de la grande distribution,
soit des commerciaux et des cadres de
l'agroalimentaire. Et souvent c'est pour
eux et des fois bah voilà il y a le
mercato, il y a pas qu'en [__] qu'il y
a du mercato. Et donc mes étudiants me
parlent et j'ai poser la question à des
jeunes associés à Intermarché à des à
des garçons qui n'ont pas de raison de
mentir à leur ancien professeur et il
est vrai
d'autres enseignes aussi non ? Voilà.
Mais mais bien sûr, mais eux ils ont
plus la liberté parce qu'ils sont
devenus pour certains patrons de magasin
maintenant et donc ils sont leurs
propres patrons. Et il est clair que il
y a aucun effort qui est fait. Quand je
vois les efforts qui ont été déployés
pour
je me dis waouh, c'est pas le même
traitement pour la guerre des prix. Mais
bien entendu, il y a un sujet qui est le
sujet le plus tabou qui soit, c'est
effectivement ce qui se passe entre
quatre murs. Parce que imaginez euh un
peu la situation si PSG devait aller
jouer sa qualification à Liverpool à
chaque fois où on joue tout le temps au
Real Madrid parce que les se passent
uniquement chez le distributeur, tout le
temps chez lui. Et quelque part ça ça
amène déjà une dissymétrie dans le
rapport de force parce que effectivement
il il choisit du lieu, il choisit du
moment, c'est beaucoup trop. Aucun
ministre alors que c'est évident, ça
pourrait changer facilement cela. Je
vous rappelle qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
gardes à vue dans notre pays sont filmé.
Pourquoi ne filme-on pas les
négociations commerciales ?
Secret commercial.
Oui, secret commercial. Mais
ça crée des affaires
non parce qu'aujourd'hui finalement ce
qui se passe dans les NGO devrait être
accessible à la DGCCRF pour bien que la
DGCF puisse remonter effectivement ce
qui s'est passé. À partir de là, il y a
un problème, il y a eu un
déréférencement, il y a une plainte.
Très bien. On fait appel effectivement
au film pour voir comment ça s'est passé
là et les échanges. C'est bien rendu
hein. C'est comme dans le film là où on
spoile pas. Spoil pas.
Voilà. À partir de là, derrière c'est
pas fait. Ça commence à faire beaucoup
de choses. La Nego est le moment clé
pour le distributeur. Et là, ils sont
tous d'accord pour pas en parler, faire
le moins de bruit possible et laisser le
film passer le plus rapidement possible.
Euh, est-ce que il y a un sujet que tu
aimerais aborder avec nous Olivier qu'on
a pas abordé ? Un truc qui te tient à
cœur ou tu penses qu'on a fait le tour ?
Mais moi, je pense au aux jeunes parce
que c'est vrai que je reste enseignant.
Tu as
J'ai 57 ans.
Ah, tu fais pas ton âge, dis donc, hein
? Ça ça conserve la Bretagne hein.
Oui. Les crêpes, le fard breton,
le beurre.
Ouais. Et euh mais je forme beaucoup de
jeunes et euh le message que je voudrais
passer pour tous les jeunes qui vont
dans des écoles de commerce qui payent
des fois certains très chers euh et qui
mettent beaucoup d'argent pour leurs
études et je leur dis à tous ces jeunes
qui étudient les sciences de gestion,
les sciences du management, l'économie,
le droit des affaires, allez voir ce
film. En regardant ce film, vous allez
apprendre beaucoup de choses et vous
aurez envie de vous intéresser
effectivement à aux affaires. Et donc je
trouve que oui, c'est le c'est vraiment
un appel pour la jeunesse parce que
j'appelle toujours la jeunesse à lire et
puis de l'autre côté à devenir à
l'époque de l'intelligence artificielle
des jeunes qui savent remettre en cause
les certitudes pour avoir bah finalement
des têtes bien faites. Parce que si on
doit s'en sortir dans le pays, c'est
parce qu'on aura aussi des têtes bien
faites. Comment tu dis en breton ? "Mami
je t'aime."
Alors ça, je sais pas dire mamie je
t'aime en Breton.
Ah, c'est dommage. Ma grand-mère va
t'engueuler. Euh Anthony, est-ce que tu
as un sujet que tu aimerais aborder avec
nous ? On n pas traité. En plus de tout
ce qu'on s'est dit, non moi
c'est non on passe autour
si mais j'aimerais quand même insister
pas tes phrases pardon il t'a expliqué
le monsieur à ta droite
un truc que je que que je t'ai dit tout
à l'heure c'est que moi j'ai envie de
lancer cet appel
aux enseignes de grande distribution
pour que elle voit le film qu'on en
parle qu'on discute qu'elle réagisse
parce que je trouve ça dommage que elle
soit pas aussi impliquée dans dans les
discussions. Moi je ça ça ça parle d'eux
donc pourquoi il prendrait pas la parole
aussi sur sur le film ?
On peut t'aider pour ça ? Et ben avec
grand plaisir.
Euh on arrive à la fin de notre
interview. Je voudrais que Olivier tu me
conseilles et que tu conseilles à la
communauté trois livres qui ont été
importants pour toi et si tu as pas
trois livres à conseiller, trois films
ou trois morceaux de musique.
J'en profite pour te laisser réfléchir.
Soutenez-nous sur Tipi, on a besoin de
vous pour continuer. C'est grâce à vous
qu'on peut inviter quand on veut, qui on
veut, autant de temps qu'on veut. et on
vous aime. Olivier, c'est à toi. Trois
bouquins.
Alors le premier bouquin pour tous ceux
qui aiment le commerce et tous ceux qui
veulent, on va dire comprendre d'où
c'est parti. Le plus grand livre sur le
management et le commerce a été écrit
par Émil Zola. Il s'appelle Au bonheur
des dames. Et au bonheur des dames,
c'est l'histoire
d'un petit monsieur en fait Zola va
reprendre et se mettre dans les pas
d'Aristi Busiko le créateur du bon
marché. Et donc Zola avec sa logique
naturaliste va rendre le magasin de
manière extraordinaire. Et on comprend
pourquoi d'ailleurs aux États-Unis Arist
Busiko est est un des personnages les
plus enseigné, le créateur du bon marché
et euh de ces grandes surfaces
spécialisées euh parce que le printemps
et puis tout ce qui arrivera derrière,
les garis la Faillette viendront de là.
et relire au bonheur des dames. Qu'on
soit chef d'entreprise, qu'on soit jeune
salarié, jeune étudiant, peu importe,
c'est un vrai plaisir. Le second livre,
c'est parce que je trouve que il faut
l'avoir lu une fois dans sa vie, c'est
l'étranger de Camu parce que c'est un
voyage en absurd et c'est peut-être
aussi se dire que voilà, la vie mérite
d'être vécue et que dans le fond, on
aura tous une femme. Il faut pas en
avoir peur. message un peu de Camu qu'on
approche la fin mais elle mérite d'être
vécu donc pas de voyage en absurdie sans
sans avoir lire l'étranger lu l'étranger
de Camu et puis l'autre c'est par
rapport au fait que c'était le premier
roman d'amour qui m'a littéralement
subjugué c'est le rouge et le noir de
Standal parce que je trouve que
l'histoire de Julien Selle et Mathilde
de la Mole est assez extraordinaire donc
j'ai appelé un de mes enfants Julien et
ma fille Mathilde suite à ça donc voilà
les ils sont au courant bien sûr Ils
sont au courant. Et donc voilà euh trois
livres que je trouve clés.
Anthony, trois bouquins ou trois films.
Ouais, je peux faire un mélange, un
film, un livre. Euh ouais, on t'autorise
parce qu'on est on est vraiment magnime
aujourd'hui.
OK. OK. Alors, un livre, je vais te
dire, mon livre de Je fais que j'adore,
c'est Martin Eden de Jack London.
J'aurais aimé même si je dois adapter un
livre un jour, ce serait celui-là au
cinéma. Ça a été fait il y a pas
longtemps par un italien et ça a été
plutôt bien fait. Donc malheureusement,
il va falloir attendre un peu. Et ça ça
rejoint aussi des thématiques qu'on
retrouve dans la dans la Guerre des prix
hein. Martin Eden, c'est un pêcheur qui
vient d'une origine très modeste et qui
va essayer de conquérir une une
bourgeoise et de devenir auteur pour
l'impressionner et qui va aussi se
confronter finalement
à cette chimère ou à cette illusion de
vouloir intégrer un système comme ça qui
lui met de la poudre aux yeux. et quand
il va rentrer dans ce système là, ça va
mal se passer pour lui. Euh, deuxième
chose, un film
Playtime de Jacques Tati. Pour moi,
c'est peut-être un des un des plus beaux
films et pareil, ça fait aussi écho à la
guerre des prix parce que c'est une
façon de montrer le monde des bureaux,
le monde moderne avec quelque chose de
très asceptisé, de très froid, de très
absurde et quelque part la façon dont
j'ai aussi filmé les bureaux peut être
directement inspiré de de tout ça. Et la
troisième chose, je vais te citer
peut-être un livre justement qui qui
c'est le premier livre que j'ai lu en
écrivant mon scénario qui s'appelle Les
coulisses de la grande distribution de
Christian Jacquyot et qui cite
d'ailleurs au bonheur des dames dans son
prologue et qui est alors qui commence à
dater un peu qui date des années 2000
mais si vous voulez voir un peu d'où on
vient dans le monde de la grande
distribution et creuser un peu le sujet
là qu'on a abordé quand vous lisez ça
waouh ça vous fait froid dans le dos
quoi.
Olivier je voudrais un conseil pour les
jeunes générations. une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui va rester
impérissable sur les réseaux.
B, je voudrais tout simplement que la
jeunesse puisse comprendre qu'il faut
garder son libre arbitre et que devant
la généralisation
de l'IA, c'est important de garder sa
capacité à douter, sa capacité à
remettre en cause les choses, la
capacité à pouvoir se projeter. Et donc
rien n'est mieux dans ces cas-là que de
pouvoir se poser dans notre monde dans
lequel tout est si rapide. Donc le
conseil c'est de pouvoir bah travailler
à garder la tête froide dans les moments
que l'on va vivre là et de pouvoir
surtout et ben douter douter pour
reconstruire. Et donc moi je crois
profondément en la jeunesse. Mais pour
se faire effectivement bah cette
jeunesse, elle a besoin de de soutien.
On a besoin qu'on l'aide à réfléchir et
donc des fois aimer ses enfants, c'est
pas toujours leur dire que tout va
toujours bien. Madame la marquise,
Anthony, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Ouais. Bah déjà de profiter de leur
jeunesse parce que je crois que
aujourd'hui on est quand même dans un
monde qui est un peu compliqué et moi
les souvenirs de jeunesse que j'ai c'est
aussi pouvoir ne pas trop se poser de
questions quand on est jeune, être assez
insouciant. Mais par contre, s'il y a
une seule qualité que je leur
conseillerais de développer, c'est la
curiosité. Et je crois que moi la
curiosité, c'est ce qui m'a permis
finalement de trouver ma voix et de
creuser ma voix en tant que cinéaste.
J'ai j'ai pas commencé par ce métierlà.
J'étais pas destiné à ça. Mais comme
j'étais curieux de tout ça et que ça m'a
intéressé, j'ai essayé de creuser, de
suivre cette voix là et ben ça m'a amené
à devenir synade. Donc je pense que
c'est très important pour les jeunes
comme pour les moins jeunes de
développer sa curiosité. Et un dernier
truc surtout les jeunes qu'ils écoutent
pas trop finalement les conseils des des
vieux cons comme nous parce que je crois
que ils ont peut-être pas besoin de
conseil en fait.
Anthony Deschud, Olivier Mvel Mercici
Merci.
Merci. Merci.